mesdames et messieurs les députés chers
collègues hier l'assemblée nationale
honorer la mémoire du général de gaulle
pour les 50 ans de sa disparition
aujourd'hui je vous demande d'avoir une
pensée pour un grand gaulliste et un
grand parlementaire qui s'est éteint il
y a vingt ans jour pour jour
jacques chaban delmas disparu le 10
novembre 2000 jacques delmas devenu le
général sabban dans la résistance compte
parmi les 67 députés ayant reçu le titre
prestigieux de compagnon de la
libération
quatorze fois élu député il siégea de
1946 1997 sans autre interruption que la
période où il fut premier ministre
de 1969 à 1972
en un demi-siècle de mandat
parlementaire
il fut six fois élu président
l'assemblée nationale fonction qu'il
exerça pendant ces années dont 11
consécutivement c'est pourquoi en 1996 à
l'initiative de philippe séguin
jacques chaban delmas fut nommé
président d'honneur de l'assemblée
nationale une distinction que notre
bureau n'avait jusqu'à leur accorder
qu'une seule fois à edouard herriot
entré dans l'histoire alors qu'il
n'avait pas 30 ans pour reprendre les
mots de philippe séguin
jacques chaban delmas fut aussi maire de
bordeaux pendant 48 ans cinq fois
ministre sous la quatrième république et
sous la vème ce premier ministre
réformateur qui tenta d'atténuer le
clivage entre la droite et la gauche
pour promouvoir la modernisation d'un
autre pays l'année dernière avec sa
famille ses anciens collaborateurs et
tous ceux qui se souviennent de son
action nous avons célébré à l'assemblée
nationale les 50 ans de son discours sur
la nouvelle société discours si en pl et
si visionnaire
humblement et respectueusement je salue
la mémoire notre président d'honneur
jacques chaban delmas l'ordre du jour
appelle les questions au gouvernement
la parole est à madame béatrice descamps
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale monsieur ministre
la crise que nous traversons nécessite
un renforcement des mesures sanitaires
pour l'ensemble des établissements
scolaires
quel que soit leur niveau votre choix de
ne pas fermer ces établissements est une
bonne décision pour tous ces jeunes dont
la vie a été tellement bouleversée et la
scolarité tellement mise à rude épreuve
depuis le printemps dernier
mais bien sûr cela ne peut s'entendre
que c'est un protocole strict peut être
respectée aussi vous avez monsieur le
ministre
ouvert au lycée de nouvelles
possibilités d'organisation de travail
dont 50% des courants distant ciel pour
n'accueillir que des deux me plaisent à
la fois tout en gardant partiellement ce
lien social si précieux grâce au
présentiel
aujourd'hui les chefs d'établissement
met tout en oeuvre pour s'adapter au
mieux et on attend souvent record au
regard et en fonction des réalités du
terrain logiquement les réponses sont
donc différentes d'un établissement à
l'autre
or monsieur le ministre le conseil
scientifique le dit la situation
sanitaire se détériore nous ne savons
pas encore aujourd'hui si les jeunes
sont ou pas contagieux entre eux un
passage au tout distant ciel est il
envisagé serons nous capables d'assurer
la continuité pédagogique
peut-on considérer que ça t'a fera
apportant repéré au printemps ont été
levées pour et ont par exemple envisager
certaines épreuves orales du bac en
distance yale
quel message pouvez vous adresser
monsieur ministres directement aux chefs
d'établissements ainsi qu'aux
enseignants dont certains sont en grève
aujourd'hui
affable et
accompagné durant cette crise sanitaire
quel message pouvez vous adresser au
lycée ya et à leurs parents pour les
rassurer
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean michel
blanc coeur ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés la
députée béatrice descamps
votre question est évidemment
essentielle elle porte sur ce qui est la
colonne vertébrale de notre vie courante
et l'accord la colonne vertébrale de la
république l'école l'organisation
mondiale de la santé a encore redit il
ya quelques jours que lorsqu'il y avait
du confinement
la dernière chose à faire mais c'était
l'école bien entendu d'abord parce que
l'école c'est fondamental l'école c'est
pas une variable d'ajustement
et ensuite parce que c'est vrai que les
études dont on peut disposer même s'il
faut être toujours très pur imprudent
montre quand même que plus un enfant est
jeune moins il ya de risque ce qui fait
d'ailleurs que la problématique est
différente pour les écoles les collèges
et les lycées
la façon dont nous avons conçu les
choses a été élaboré au mois de juillet
à la lumière de ce que le haut conseil
de la santé publique avait élaboré nous
avons donc élaboré à la fois un
protocole sanitaire connaissant
plusieurs degrés et un protocole de
continuité pédagogique
ce protocole sanitaire numéro 1 s'est
appliqué en septembre il a été une
réussite puisque nous avons pu faire
revenir tous les élèves et tous les
professeurs
ce qui n'est pas le cas dans tous les
pays et puis il n'a nous a permis de
faire classe de septembre à octobre à
partir du moment où il ya eu à prendre
des mesures plus graves
nous n'avons pas changé de nature mais
2° autrement dit c'est comme si nous
inventions un curseur nous sommes passés
au protocole numéro deux avec des
mesures barrières plus forte et nous
sommes encore là dedans maintenant
et puis nous prenons des mesures
éventuelles pour arriver à ce qui est
moins de brassage donc moins d'élèves et
nous l'avons fait avec le lycée
récemment en concertation très étroite
avec les chefs d'établissements
vous avez eu raison de différer ference
comeau professeur de façon à avoir
quelque chose de pragmatique pragmatique
ça veut dire cadrage national mais aussi
mesures locales pour s'adapter à chaque
réalité
alors oui nous avons travaillé sur les
contenus qui sont d'ailleurs visibles
par tous
aujourd'hui sur nos sites et puis aussi
sur les équipements avec les
collectivités locales pour qu'il puisse
y avoir de l'enseignement a dit
danse de la meilleure qualité possible
et donc nous oui nous sommes prêts à
faire encore évoluer le curseur dans un
sens ou dans un autre mais mon objectif
c'est évidemment l'ouverture maximale
parce que c'est le droit à l'éducation
de nos enfants je vous remercie merci
monsieur ministre la parole est à
monsieur marc le fur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre il ya 50 ans
disparaissait le général de gaulle le
président de la république vous même le
président de l'assemblée chacun à sa
manière a rendu hommage à l'homme celui
qui sauva l'honneur à 40 celui qui dans
les années 60 rétablir notre économie et
nos comptes publics
celui qui dot à notre pays
d'institutions solides mais aussi
respectueuse des libertés en particulier
lorsqu'il fallut prendre des mesures
d'exception limitant les libertés
publiques
il veille à ce que ce soit le plus bref
possible au delà de la personne du
général de gaulle il y a un héritage de
valeurs
la première de ces valeurs c'est la
souveraineté la crise du coc vide a
révélé la défaillance totale de notre
souveraineté sanitaire masse médicaments
la souveraineté d'etel pas entamer
aujourd'hui lorsque nous empruntons
massivement à l'étranger la souveraineté
c'est aussi notre indépendance
alimentaire
le général de gaulle y tenait il avait
imposé la pac
envisagez-vous toujours de nous imposer
la ratification du ceta qui est le
préalable à la fin de cette souveraineté
au coeur de la souveraineté il y à la
frontière si essentiel en cette période
de grandes migrations
vous êtes vous donner les moyens de
tenir cette frontière
monsieur le premier ministre en avez
vous la volonté
le gaullisme c'est aussi la capacité à
fixer un cap c'est précisément pleine
crise alors chez que chacun pense à
l'immédiat il nous faut un cap pour le
long terme
alors quel cap nous proposez vous le
gaullisme enfin c'est la capacité à
faire partager ce cap cette ambition
collective à tous petits et grands
jamais de gaulle n'aurait employer
l'expression ceux qui ne sont rien ils
savaient au contraire que c'était les
plus modestes qu'il avait rejoint il
savait au contraire il n'avait pas
oublié que c'était les pêcheurs de l'île
de sein qui les premiers avaient été à
ses côtés en juin 40 alors monsieur le
premier ministre vous donnez vous les
moyens d'être fidèle à ce bel héritage
qui nous est commun à tous merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
madame roselyne bachelot ministre de la
culture
[Applaudissements]
non mais je suis extrêmement honoré une
mesure président confie la tâche de
répondre à cette question filles fils de
résistant gaulliste depuis toujours cet
honneur mettra tout le monde a été est
ou sera gaulliste comme l'a dit
exactement malraux dont j'ai l'honneur
d'occuper le bureau aujourd'hui dans une
sorte de filiation qui l'a aussi
m'honore je crois qu'il ne convient pas
dans cette période de recueillement de
faire parler le général de gaulle
qu'aurait-il fait comment aurait il
réagi dans un contexte totalement inédit
je crois que nous ne devons nous
souvenir que d'une chose que vous avez
ce qui c'est c'est les leçons qui nous a
laissé les leçons de dévouement des tic
de la responsabilité d'ascèse dans
l'exercice du pouvoir et ça c'est la
seule chose dont nous devons nous
souvenir et je crois que nous ne sommes
là finalement à la suite du général de
gaulle cas nous reconnaître dans cette
phrase qui l'adresser à la france mère
tel que nous sommes nous sommes là pour
vous servir et c'est ce qui nous réunit
tous ensemble
mais aussi valable amélie
la parole est à monsieur jean-noël
barrot merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre les
députés du groupe modem et démocrate
apparenté salue l'élection de joe biden
46e président des états unis d'amérique
et celle de kamala harris première femme
à devenir vice-présidente de cette
grande nation
nous saluons et nous saluons aussi la
mobilisation historique des citoyens
américains qui en pleine crise sanitaire
se sont plus massivement exprimés qui ne
l'avait fait depuis 120 ans dans ce
sursaut démocratique le vote à distance
aura joué un rôle clé 65 millions de
citoyens américains ont voté à distance
sans qu'aucun cas de fraude ne soit
avérée à ce jour s'il y a une seule
leçon à tirer de tout cela c'est que la
progression de l'abstention de scrutin
en scrutin n'est pas une fatalité que la
france peut elle aussi traverser les
crises sans avoir à mettre la démocratie
à l'arrêt et que nos concitoyens ne
doivent pas avoir à choisir entre
l'expression de leurs droits civiques et
leur santé la france a renoncé au vote
par correspondance en 1975 pour des
risques de fraude
cinquante ans plus tard ne sommes nous
pas capables de les maîtriser nos
collègues représentant les français de
l'étranger dans cet hémicycle ont été
élus par correspondance sont ils moins
légitime
nous ne croyons pas et c'est la raison
pour laquelle les députés démocrates ont
déposé dès le mois de juin une
proposition de loi pour inviter le
gouvernement à ouvrir le chantier du
vote à distance
six mois plus tard le virus est toujours
là
six mois plus tard il est toujours aussi
urgent d'ouvrir le chantier du vote à
distance
c'est un chantier difficile c'est un
chantier exigeant mais monsieur le
ministre vous qui avez réussi le tour de
force contre les vents contraires de
mettre en oeuvre le prélèvement à la
source pour nous compter sur vous pour
ouvrir sans délai le chantier du vote à
distance
merci chers collègues la parole est un
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
monsieur le député monsieur débuté
barreaux merci d'avoir permis de montrer
que l'intégralité de la représentation
nationale était favorable à l'impôt à la
source est désormais s'en félicite
chaque jour j'imagine dans chacune de
leurs circonscriptions
vous avez souhaité saluer l'élection du
président byden et son vice président le
président de la république s'est exprimé
vous avez ceux dé souligner qu'en pleine
pandémie les électeurs ont pu voter et
ont utilisé notamment le vote à distance
pour pouvoir voter
vous avez évoqué ce sujet pour
l'exporter si j'ose dire en france
permettez moi de penser malgré tout et
sans porter de jugement le semis des
affaires étrangères sur le scrutin aux
américains que le système électoral
français fonctionne et que ce système
électoral français il correspond sans
doute un certain nombre de critères qui
empêche peut-être d'aller vers le vote à
distance comme vous l'évoquez d'abord
une question évidemment de lutte contre
la fraude vous avez soulevé que sous la
présidence de giscard d'estaing du
président giscard d'estaing nous avions
supprimé pour raison de fraudes et des
raisons de l'exportation postale qui
n'ont pas beaucoup changé depuis des
années 70 même si évidemment le service
public de la poste contribue évidemment
à la vie électorale par l'intermédiaire
de faire porter les plis des bulletins
de vote ou les professions de foi mais
parfois on peut le constater chacun peut
le constater nos élections où il a pu se
présenter avec un certain retard poste
jour de l'élection
deuxièmement monsieur le député ne soit
pas capable aujourd'hui de cadre au
ministère de l'intérieur en tout cas
mais la réflexion peut se poser d'être
sûr que ce scrutin comme le scrutin
électronique soit entièrement
incontestable vu que effectivement avec
des cas de fraudes peuvent être relevés
et nous avons fait le choix de l'isoloir
de l'urne et des préaux d'école pour
caricaturer point bonne et simple raison
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement fort
dans le scrutin électoral français c'est
que un tiers ne peut pas faire deux
poids communautaire
d'une fête du mari envers sa femme sa
femme envers son mari ou d'une personne
sur une autre du père sur ses enfants
par exemple ou la mère ses enfants pour
voter librement dans un isoloir
je souhaite pour ma part qu'on puisse
continuer à voter librement dans un
isoloir
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame s'il vous plaît
la parole est à madame chantal jourdan
et elle seule
merci monsieur le président mec
merci monsieur président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
hier la presse s'est fait l'écho des
résultats annoncés par les sociétés
fighter et bio ntech concernant
l'efficacité à 90% du vaccin contre la
copie de 19,6 cette annonce suscite
l'espoir
elle interroge quant à la préparation de
notre pays sur la stratégie de
vaccination 13 en un mot il faut
souligner le manque d'ambition de notre
pays sur la question de la recherche
d'un vaccin
l'allemagne a débloqué 627 millions
d'euros en septembre dernier pour
notamment soutenir du one tech
qu'en est il des investissements de
notre pays dans ce domaine lui
aujourd'hui union européenne au nom de
ses états membres a commandé 200
millions de doses avec une option pour
100 millions de plus
début septembre l'union comptant plus de
440 millions d'habitants se pose la
question de la répartition de ses
premières doses entre les pays pouvez
vous monsieur le ministre nous indiquer
le protocole décidé pour la répartition
de ces vaccins entre les européens
second point celui de la stratégie de
vaccination le 13 octobre
mon collègue boris vallot vous
interrogez déjà alors que dès le 9
juillet le conseil scientifique rendait
un avis intitulé propositions sur la
stratégie de vaccination vous nous
indiquiez mi-octobre que tout était en
cours de préparation
hier la haute autorité de santé a lancé
une consultation publique jusqu'au 30
novembre sur cette question et
présentera ses résultats début 2021
nous sommes donc en retard il est urgent
aujourd'hui de préparer la vaccination
des français et d'en définir
l'organisation qu'il s'agisse de la
chaîne d'approvisionnement et de
distribution des vaccins
celui-ci de 20 heures
peut-être conservé à -80 degré de la
répartition du sol de la répartition sur
le sol national des personnels habilités
à faire ces vaccins médecins infirmières
pharmaciens et des publics prioritaires
nous devons être prêts monsieur le
ministre pouvez vous nous détailler la
stratégie de vaccination de notre pays
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole des cadres y attaquer
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
je t'en remercie beaucoup pour votre
question qui effectivement me donne
l'occasion de faire le point sur cette
annonce du laboratoire pfizer fait hier
à la fois porteuse d'espoir soixante
d'entre nous et il faut s'en réjouir
mais également qui doit susciter la
prudence en l'état actuel des
connaissances
je tiens à rappeler tout d'abord madame
la députée que la france dès le début
dès l'apparition de ce virus en lien
avec les travaux conduits par la
commission européenne s'est très tôt
mobiliser pour que les français
disposent d'un accès un maximum de type
de candidat vaccin y compris celui
développé par pfizer mais exact
également par d'autres sociétés comme
astrazeneca
alors oui enthousiasme et espoir que
peuvent susciter est différente et les
récentes annonces il faut néanmoins les
tempérer les vaccins contre le colis 19
ne pourront pas être mis à disposition
qu'après avoir satisfait vous le savez à
toutes les exigences de sécurité
aujourd'hui le laboratoire on est à la
phase 3 de d'expérimentation les tests
ont été faits au près de 40000 personnes
vingt mille personnes porteuses du virus
et vermine qui était du vaccin pardon et
20000 disposons d'un effet placebo il y
a encore au moins un mois de test a
occasionné afin avant que les autorités
sanitaires à la fois américaines et
européennes puissent disposer de
l'ensemble des données et puissent
valider et mettre sur marché sur le
marché
ces vaccins donc nous ne sommes pas en
retard contrairement à ce que vous
évoquez madame la députée puisque vous
voulez que l'horizon est plutôt à fin
décembre janvier dans les meilleurs des
carmes et la haute autorité dans le même
la haute autorité dans le même temps
travaillent à l'élaboration des
recommandations qui permettront de fixer
la politique de vaccination déterminer
quelles seront effectivement les
éventuels public
prioritaires qui devront pouvoir
bénéficier de ce vaccin dans l'union
européenne et au sein du territoire
national évidemment on peut penser au
public prioritaire par exemple
aujourd'hui destinataires des vaccins
pour la grippe comme les soignants ou
les personnes vulnérables comme le
sentez le code de la santé publique le
prévoit et comme c'est le cas pour
chaque vaccin mêmes modalités
d'utilisation des recommandations seront
décidées par ims de la santé après
recommandations de la haute autorité de
santé merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur sébastien jumel
madame la ministre
un bon parfum des grandes marques
françaises coûtent vite cher 100 euros
savez vous combien revient à ceux qui
fabriquent le flacon chez moi dans la
glass vallée seulement 1 euro pour ce
bel objet en verre 2 euros pour le jus 3
pour le décor et l'emballage mais 25%
pour la publicité du parfum 35 pour sa
distribution et 15 euros pour la marge
de la marque 1 euros le flacon c'est
très peu mais il ya pourtant derrière
beaucoup de savoir-faire ouvriers 70
entreprises et surtout 7000 salariés et
leurs familles alors que dans la vallée
de la bresle la plus ouvrière de france
la filière du flaconnage de luxe subit
une baisse de 40% de sa production
les grands du luxe français comme si de
rien n'était continuent à faire leurs
courses à l'étranger pour 200 millions
d'euros de flacons c'est l'équivalent du
chiffre d'affaires des grosses
entreprises verrière dans mon coin
l'équivalent de 1500 emplois directs
alors qu'une partie de l'activité de
luxe bénéficie de la reprise en chine
lvmh l'oréal
yves rocher pour ne citer que ceux là
doivent jouer leur rôle
le jeu du patriotisme industriel pour
éviter des choses simples que les
salariés soit la variable d'ajustement
que d'autres filières qui produit 70% du
flaconnage perdre ses savoir faire et
pour éviter qu'une guerre fratricide se
s'organise entre les verriers cette
proposition simple concrète offensive
que nous faisons avec le syndicat cgt
des verriers est la suivante au delà des
mesures défensives conjoncturelle les
toits doit convaincre les deux d'or
d'ordre de jouer la carte du patriotisme
industriel
s'il ne veut pas se contenter de jouer
demain les pompiers pour vous permettre
de joindre la parole sur la souveraineté
industrielle aux actes
nous vous demandons de réunir avec nous
la filière du flaconnage et ses grands
groupes français qui ont largement
bénéficié de vos cadeaux fiscaux pour
discuter concrètement du patriotisme
industriel
êtes vous prêts à cela madame la
ministre dans l'ivresse du parfum le
flacon les hommes et les femmes qui le
fabrique importe beaucoup plus que le
prix croyez nous merci monsieur le
député la parole est à madame agnès
pannier une hache et ministre délégué
chargé de l'industrie merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député jumelles
permettez moi d'abord d'excusés bruno le
maire dont vous savez l'attachement à la
vallée de la bresle et qui connaît votre
engagement auprès des entreprises de
cette glace vallée qui fait notre fierté
il préside aujourd'hui le copil le
comité de pilotage du plan de relance
car le plan de relance est en train de
se déployer sur tous les territoires et
je ferai le lien avec ce plan de relance
puisque les entreprises de cette vallée
de la bresle que nous avons visité
ensemble il y a quelques semaines
je pense notamment à vergt et sens je
pense à pau chez
ont bénéficié de ce plan de relance qui
vont permettre vous voyez c'est des
hôtesses et des entreprises de nos
territoires qui vont permettre
d'accompagner leur décarbonation et leur
modernisation
donc voilà c'est très concret et nous
sommes évidemment aux côtés de ces
entreprises et pour rebondir sur votre
question sur les achats je veux dire ici
que à la suite de cette visite je me
suis rapproché de l'oréal et de lvmh
justement pour les interroger alors je
le ferai auprès de la troisième
entreprise que vous avez cités
évidemment pour les interroger sur ce
paradoxe qui conduit pour 10 centimes
d'écart à acheter un flacon à l'étranger
plutôt qu'en france et nous avons
commencé à travailler ensemble justement
pour regarder comment ils peuvent
prendre des engagements et vous savez
qu'ils sont sont réunis le 15 octobre
dernier qui eut des états généraux de la
filière cosmétique et de la filière
parfum et qu'ils ont pris des
engagements en ce sens et nous allons
continuer à travailler avec eux comme
nous le faisons aujourd'hui dans les 18
filières avec philippe varin puisque
j'ai demandé à chaque filière d'avoir
une politique d'achats responsables avec
des donneurs d'ordre qui soit
responsable vis-à-vis de leurs sous
traitants
cette solidarité elle est plus que
jamais nécessaire dans la crise que nous
traversons aujourd'hui cette solidarité
elle va jusqu'au conseil national des
achats puisque nous sommes en train de
regarder
produit par produit ce qui peut être
relocalisés certainement pas tout mais
c'est peut être relocalisés au profit de
l'entreprise française simone grand
merci monsieur le président le peuple
américain s'est prononcé avec clarté le
20 janvier prochain
joe biden deviendra le 46e président des
états unis d'amérique pour beaucoup et
j'en fais partie
l'élection de joe van den heede kamala
harris qui deviendra la première vice
présidente de l'histoire du pays est une
formidable source d'espoir dans un monde
instable des perspectives de coopération
nouvelle s'ouvre je pense évidemment la
mise en oeuvre de l'accord de paris sur
le climat
je pense à l'indispensable coordination
pour endiguer l'épidémie de covin et
pour répondre à la crise je pense aussi
à la question de notre sécurité
collective et à la lutte contre le
terrorisme
l'espoir est là et pourtant pourtant
devant nos yeux éberlués se concrétise
aujourd'hui une leçon de l'histoire
s'il est facile pour une nation de
succomber au populisme parvenir à en
sortir est autrement plus compliqué
le président sortant tente désormais
d'utiliser toutes les voies possibles
pour contester les résultats du scrutin
devant les tribunaux des états c'est
classique et c'est la voix légitime mais
aussi en encourageant à mi-mots la
désobéissance civile des plus acharnés
de ses partisans et en mobilisant
désormais un appareil administratif et
judiciaire fédérale largement à sa main
monsieur le premier ministre
au delà des politiques que nous pouvons
mettre en oeuvre il y avait une question
plus essentiel encore c'est la question
de nos valeurs
c'est la question des valeurs communes à
la france et aux états unis des valeurs
qui nous ont réunis dans les moments les
plus cruciaux de nos histoires comme une
des valeurs qui au fond se résume en un
mot la démocratie monsieur le premier
ministre
comment la france et l'europe peuvent
tel aujourd'hui contribuer à encourager
le respect de la démocratie en amérique
je vous remercie merci monsieur les buts
et la parole à monsieur jean yves le
drian vis de l'europe des affaires
étrangères monsieur le député et grands
sont le choix par le peuple américain du
futur président joe biden et de la
future vice-présidente kamala harris à
première femme vice-présidente est
d'abord le résultat d'une grande
mobilisation démocratique il faut la
saluer car la participation des
électeurs au choix de leurs
représentants est toujours une bonne
nouvelle pour la démocratie je dois dire
ici que les états unis ont montré une
grande vitalité démocratique et ont
montré
qu'ils étaient une grande démocratie un
nouveau chapitre va désormais s'ouvrir
il faut que nous puissions construire un
agenda nouveau avec la future
administration américaine
nous aurons beaucoup à faire dans une
relation qui devra être équilibré
beaucoup à faire ensemble
mais le retour annoncé par le président
élu à la méthode du multilatéralisme
notamment sur des sujets aussi cruciaux
que le changement climatique qui est la
première priorité internationale fixé
par joe hogan est un signal encourageant
sur notre capacité d'action commune
mais dans le même temps chacun doit en
convenir le monde a changé depuis quatre
ans c'est pourquoi la relation
transatlantique devra être refondée
rééquilibrer pour prendre en
considération cette nouvelle réalité une
réalité dans laquelle les européens
doivent prendre toute leur place comme
ils ont commencé à le faire davantage
ces dernières années c'est l'intérêt des
etats-unis eux-mêmes que de pouvoir
compter sur des partenaires européens
renforcer plus volontaires et et plus
déterminé une réalité dans laquelle nous
aurons à défendre nos valeurs communes
nos intérêts la recherche de solutions
communes pour nous mêmes mais aussi pour
les états unis voient une feuille de
route très conséquente que nous aurons à
mettre en oeuvre avec la nouvelle
administration américaine
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
un monsieur michel herbillon
merci ma question s'adresse au ministre
des affaires étrangères un nouveau
président des états unis joe biden vient
d'être élu et je tiens au nom du groupe
l'est républicain à le féliciter et à
lui souhaiter plein succès dans
l'exercice de son mandat
emmanuel macron a salué son élection en
indiquant je cite nous avons beaucoup à
faire pour relever les défis
d'aujourd'hui
agissons ensemble encore ne faut-il pas
que cette volonté reste une incantation
mais se traduisent en actes concrets et
en résultats car hélas dans le domaine
international comme dans bien d'autres
les actes suivent rarement les paroles
présidentielles
et c'est bien par un manque de résultats
et par une succession d'échecs que s'est
traduite la relation entre la france et
les états unis sur tous les dossiers
clés pour emmanuel macron il n'a pas
empêché leur départ de l'accord de paris
sur le climat ni du traité sur le
nucléaire iranien alors qu'il s'était
fait fort de les y faire revenir il a
fait preuve de naïveté on ne percevant
pas que les états unis voulaient mener
une politique unilatérale et mettre en
cause les organisations internationales
comme le ms l'om c'est l'unesco et
l'alliance atlantique au sein de
l'otan'' en appliquant même des
sanctions extraterritoriale pour les
entreprises françaises
alors oui désormais la france et
l'europe devront construire une nouvelle
relation avec les états unis la nouvelle
équipe mais il faut le faire sans
illusion car il y aura une certaine
forme de continuité dans la politique
étrangère américaine et les états unis
continueront d'abord et avant tout à
défendre les intérêts des états unis
leur priorité risque de ne pas être le
partenariat avec l'europe mais leurs
relations avec la chine nouvelle
puissance antagonistes des états unis
dans ce contexte
pouvez vous nous dire monsieur le
ministre sur quelles nouvelles bases
plus réalistes sans illusion excessive
j'ose orienter la politique étrangère de
la france et la nouvelle relation à
construire avec les états unis afin de
passer des souhaits et des rêves aux
actes et aux résultats
merci monsieur débuté la parole de
monsieur jean yves le drian venise de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
c'est le député herbillon quand même je
vous connais je suis surpris que vous
vouliez faire porter à au président mac
rend des décisions qui ont été prises
par le président tron
là votre votre rigueur intellectuelle
que je pense est sincère et réel ne
paraît vous échapper mais je voudrais
simplement vous dire que oui
le président macron a félicité le
président et le président byden de son
élection et oui il y à des ouvertures et
des synergies nouvelles qui apparaissent
devant nous non particulier pour la
défense des biens publics mondiaux et
sur la refondation du système
multilatéraliste ya déjà des signes par
les affirmations de président élu byden
sur la lutte contre le changement
climatique je les ai évoqué ce sera un
élément de convergence très important et
ça va nous permettre le retour des
etats-unis dans l'accord de paris qui
indiqué le président élu byden sera un
des ses premiers actes permettra de
préparer ensemble dans une bonne
synergie les échéances importants qui
sont devant nous en particulier la cop16
de glasgow
c'est vrai aussi dans le domaine de la
santé publique mondiale nous aurons à
travailler ensemble dans le cadre de l'
oms reconstitué de nous aurons à
travailler ensemble pour lutter plus
efficacement contre la pandémie et pour
la réforme du multilatéralisme de la
santé nous avons aussi un grand enjeu
autour du partenariat économique
transatlantique c'est vrai sur le
commerce nous avons besoin d'un dialogue
plus approfondi et j'espère d'une
collaboration pour la refonte de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce est
un sujet qui est devant nous est
indiscutablement et puis nous aurons
aussi à travailler ensemble sur le
numérique pour le autour du triptyque
régulation taxation et définition de
normes plus l'enjeu de la sécurité et la
défense
le fait qu'il y ait eu un engagement
dans le cadre de l'otan a développé une
réflexion stratégique autour du concept
futures de l'alliance ce sera un
incitateur pour une meilleure relation
oui un agenda très riche qui se doit
amener à une relation transatlantique
équilibré et refonder merci
ap aaron auto monsieur le président
bertrand pancher
monsieur le premier ministre depuis le
début du 2ème confinement les critiques
montent sur l'application des règles
sanitaires dans les collèges et lycées
personnels enseignants élèves parents
d'élèves des collectivités font état
d'un sentiment d'un préparation les
enseignants sont aujourd'hui en grève
on demande aux enseignants d'effectuer
les cours en présentiel et en même temps
de suivre les jeunes qui vont rester
chez eux et décrocher mission impossible
nous réclamons l'embauchent
d'auxiliaires éducatif il y a des
enfants à qui les parents auront les
moyens de payer des cours par
correspondance ou belles tablettes et
les autres qui à nouveau
faute de moyens ou de réseau suffisant
vont rester au bord du chemin
on va encore renforcer les inégalités
vous aviez annoncé une prime pour les
équipements informatiques 27 juillet
pourriez vous nous dire précisément où
nous en sommes on met en place un
protocole sanitaire à la va vite
ce qui pose de gros problèmes aux
collectivités territoriales en termes de
restauration scolaire notamment les
collectivités sont excédés ne remonte
enfin le fait que personne n'applique
réellement la nécessité de proposer des
salles dédiées au dédoublement des
enseignements et que les protocoles
serait appliquée de façon différente
entre les territoires
qu'en est-il par exemple de l'aération
des salles de classe pouvez vous
monsieur le premier ministre répondre à
ces questions
avez vous tenu compte des enseignements
du premier confinement afin de ne pas
aboutir à nouveau à une cacophonie et
une démobilisation de tous merci
monsieur présent dans par l'état
monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs député monsieur le
président paychère hier dans les
établissements de santé français
551 de nos compatriotes sont décédés il
y en avait quatre 1690 qui était
hospitalisée en réanimation et environs
31000 hospitalisés pour cause de
qu'ovide 31000 40% d'entre eux ont moins
de 65 ans l'autre taux d'incidence vous
le savez avoisine les 400 30 pour cent
mille personnes et j'appelle votre
attention que hier dans 11 pays de
l'europe ce taux d'incidence a dépassé
les 500 licences
c'est dire si la situation est
préoccupante et le demeure c'est dire si
elle a justifié le recours un nouveau
confinement un nouveau confinement qu'il
est je le redis ici dans cet hémicycle
indispensable de respecter ce qu'on
ciment et nous avons tiré les leçons du
premier
nous avons écouté ce qui a été dit je
crois surtout les bancs l'école et les
établissements d'enseignement mérite un
traitement spécifique car nous savons
car nous savons que confiné les élèves
peut-être pire peut être pire que de les
laisser se rendre dans les
établissements et c'est le choix qu'a
fait le gouvernement
ils l'appliquent monsieur le président
comme toujours avec beaucoup de
pragmatisme mais
avec une seule ligne de conduite la
sécurité sanitaire de nos concitoyens en
l'espèce des enfants et des enseignants
comme vous l'a expliqué tout à l'heure
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
nous avions dès le mois de juillet
prévue des protocoles sanitaires
applicables dans ces établissements avec
des degrés de déclenchement corrélée à
la situation sanitaire mais aussi à
l'organisation et à la situation de ces
établissements pour les lycées en
particulier puisque vous les avez cités
nous avons le ministre dès le 5 novembre
expliqué et reconnu que pour améliorer
la sécurité sanitaire des adaptations
dans l'organisation des enseignements
pouvaient être adaptées avec comme ligne
conductrice
le fait de ne laisser aucun enfant de
côté et je voudrais ici devant la
représentation nationale rendre hommage
rendre hommage aux élus locaux aux
enseignants à toute la communauté
éducative qui fait en sorte qui fait en
sorte que globalement tout se passe très
bien
vous avez raison il y a eu des
contestations il y a eu des
contestations il y avait aujourd'hui
vous y avez fait référence monsieur le
président un mouvement de grève selon
les chiffres en ma possession
aujourd'hui il a été suivi par 8,38 %
des enseignants
je prends acte de cette information que
je vous livre
nous continuerons à être mobilisé en
fonction de la gravité de la situation
sanitaire avec sérieux sans démagogie
avec détermination et un seul objectif
assurer la sécurité de tous nos
concitoyens
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre c'est
le président penche r oui monsieur le
premier ministre
tout est compliqué mais c'est parce
qu'ils me remontent du terrain en tout
cas ce que vous nous dites anticipation
transparence concertation c'est aussi la
clé pour surmonter la crise est vraiment
que je trouve je trouve dommage vous dis
je trouve dommage que l'éducation
nationale dans ce domaine ne montre pas
en permanence l'exemple merci monsieur
le président la parole est à madame
françoise dumas merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre je rentre
ce jour de la bande sahélo-saharienne je
me suis rendu avec une délégation de la
commission de la défense
ce déplacement fait suite à ce que vous
même monsieur le ministre de l'europe et
des affaires étrangères avait effectué
au début du mois avec ce rainbow borgne
nathalie serre qui sont co rapporteur
d'une mission d'information sur
l'opération barkan ainsi que
jean-jacques ferrara nous avons été à la
rencontre de nos forces déployées dans à
niamey cacao
nous avons également échangé avec les
autorités civiles locales en particulier
le gouverneur de gao
ainsi qu'avec les membres des forces
armées maliennes et de l'ensemble de
celles engagées au sein de la force
conjointe du g5 serre nous avons pu
constater les incontestables progrès
réalisés depuis le début de l'année
la dynamique de sa réalisation engagé
par le sommet de peau du 13 janvier 2020
fait ses preuves en témoigne le récent
succès de l'opération bourrasques
conduite en partenariat avec les forces
locales celle ci a mobilisé plus de 3000
soldats dont 1600 français 1100
nigériens et 300 malien véritable succès
tactiques et opérationnels
elle est également associé les forces
spéciales franco estonienne de la task
force takouba en coopération avec une
unité légère de reconnaissance et
d'intervention malienne si elle a porté
un coup dur aux groupes armés
terroristes dans la zone des trois
frontières
le succès de boer à ce que tient aussi
et surtout est la parfaite collaboration
entre les forces locales
la force conjointe du g5 sahel la force
barkan et nos partenaires y compris
d'ailleurs américain engagé sur ce
théâtre elle nous montre donc la voie à
suivre
d'importants défis se dressent néanmoins
face à nous afin d'intensifier la
formation et l'équipement des forces
locales et d'accroître la participation
nos alliés aux occidentaux et en premier
les européens
madame la ministre quels sont selon vous
les perspectives et les priorités en la
matière je vous remercie merci nos
prisons la parole est à madame florence
parly ministre désormais merci monsieur
le président madame la présidente
il ya les perspectives et puis elle
bilan par vous avez mentionné une
opération d'ampleur dans sa coordination
avec les armées du niger et du mali
l'opération bourrasque qui a été en
effet une vraie démonstration de force
qui a permis ensemble de porter des
coups sévères au à l'état islamique au
grand sahara
il ya eu aussi des actions
d'opportunités il y en a encore eu une
ce week-end avec la neutralisation de
plus de 60 terroristes
grâce à la combinaison de nos moyens
aériens y compris des drones armés en
appui des forces terrestres des troupes
au sol
et puis enfin il ya la force et à kouba
qui composait de forces spéciales pour
l'instant française et estonienne et qui
a conduit ses premières opérations en
soutien des forces armées maliennes
alors je voudrais voir dans ces
opérations et dans ces succès la
confirmation que nous sommes sur la
bonne voie et qu'il faut donc poursuivre
avec détermination dans les mois à venir
lors pour commencer je voudrais insister
sur les forces de nos partenaires du
sahel puisque ce sont elles que nous
voulons renforcer que nous voulons aider
à s'aguerrir pour pouvoir reprendre peu
à peu du terrain et j'ai pu constater
par moi-même que lorsque le terrain et
réoccuper alors la vie revient il y aura
aussi deux mains plus d'européens au
sahel la force takouba sera renforcée se
prépare nos camarades tchèque également
suédois qui doivent peuvent arriver au
début de l'année 2000 21
et puis les italiens se prépare avec des
capacités d'évacuation médicale le
portugal est lui
rennes également envisage la
participation avec volontarisme
il y a aussi le doublement de la mission
upm la mission formation de l'union
européenne à l'horizon 2021
il y aura enfin plus de coordination
vous en avez parlé c'est essentiel pour
permettre la montée en gamme de la force
conjointe et des forces armées
nationales
et puis il faut aussi bien sûr continuer
à maintenir la pression sur ds mais
aussi sur la l'al-qaïda qui a également
appelé encore récemment au jihad
individuel jihad individuel sur notre
sol
merci merci madame la ministre la parole
à madame danielle obono monsieur le
premier ministre
après la chine l'an dernier la russie mi
août le laboratoire des états unis
fighter a annoncé hier les résultats
provisoires d'un vaccin contre la copie
de 19 qui serait efficace à 90%
la nouvelle suscite très naturellement
de l'espoir mais aussi un certain nombre
d'interrogations auxquelles il est
impératif de répondre si vous nous
voulons créer les conditions d'une
adhésion éclairé de la population et de
l'efficacité vaccinale en effet un
vaccin même efficace à 100% mais qui ne
serait utilisé que par moins de 60% de
la population n'aurait pas d'impact
contre la pandémie
c'est aussi pour cela qu'il faut
s'assurer de son accès universel partout
dans le monde et qu'ils ne fassent pas
l'objet d'une indécente et
contreproductif marche marchandisation
pour le moment nous ne disposons pas des
résultats complets de l'essai ni du
protocole de recherche
or ledit vaccin est déjà en prévente les
etats-unis ont conclu dès juillet en
accord avec five faveur de 1,95 milliard
de dollars pour obtenir 100 millions de
doses avec la possibilité d'en acheter
500 millions de plus l'union européenne
a aussi passé une commande de 300
millions de doses qu'elle aurait seul
pouvoir de redistribuer ensuite à chaque
pays la course au vaccin peut nuire à
son efficacité et à son accessibilité
le modèle de compétition et
d'accélération des procédures qui s'est
imposée pour répondre à la crise n'est
pas le plus pertinent et fait courir le
risque d'aboutir à des vaccins médiocre
alors moi monsieur le premier ministre
avez vous prévu pour s'assurer de la
transparence des protocoles de recherche
de ce vaccin comme des autres vaccins
candidats
ce que demandent instamment nombre
d'associations et de collectifs comme
l'observatoire des politiques de la
transparence des médicaments où en sont
également les recherches en france et
comment comptez vous garantir notre
souveraineté en matière de production et
de distribution et l'accès de tous et
toutes à l'échelle mondiale aux vaccins
et médicaments
merci mme le député l'apport le tchadri
attaqué secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre des solidarités de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
obono vous avez parlé du vaccin comme un
comme un bien universel et je vous
rejoins sur ce point et je crois que
vous êtes d'accord avec quelqu'un qui
dès le 24 avril dernier a même parlé de
bien public mondial
et cette personne s'était manuel macron
qui dès le 24 avril a insisté sur la
nécessité que le vaccin soit un bien
public mondial
pourquoi parce que ce virus vous le
savez n'a pas de frontière et que donc
protéger les autres eh bien ça nous
protéger nous mêmes alors la
collaboration que le président de la
république a dès le mois d'avril
initiée au niveau européen et
international repose autour de quatre
piliers d'une part faire en sorte que le
financement pour la recherche soient
menées et qu'il y ait plusieurs
recherches qu'ils soient menées de
concert vous avez cité fire dont je vous
rappelle qu'il est en lien en co
opération pardon avec un laboratoire
allemand bio et ventech deuxièmement la
question de la production
troisièmement de la distribution et
enfin que nous soyons tous instants tiff
au renforcement des systèmes de santé
dans les pays les plus vulnérables parce
que quand bien même nous aurions trouvé
un vaccin il ya besoin de systèmes de
santé qui puisse faire en sorte de
vacciner les personnes dès le 4 mai et
le 18 mai sous l'impulsion du président
emmanuel macron deux conférences de
financement ont eu lieu dans le cadre de
l'union européenne afin de disposer des
fonds pour accéler la recherche
accélérer la recherche et faire en sorte
que l'ensemble des pays dans le monde
l'ensemble des citoyens puissent avoir
accès à ce vaccin
cette coopération enfin elle se fait aux
trois niveaux évidemment au niveau
national au niveau européen je les dis
et au niveau international dans le cadre
de l' oms c'est l'action que nous menons
dès avril dernier afin de faire en sorte
que ce vaccin soit bien un bien public
mondial
merci monsieur lisbonne a beau boulot
heureusement au delà du discours
les réponses ne sont de notre point de
vue pas suffisantes notamment sur la
question de la souveraineté
thérapeutique en france
et comme la planification n'a pas été
votre fort jusqu'à présent dans cette
crise je crains que nous devions
continuer à vous interpeller sur ce
sujet merci avant de lui donner la
parole je suis heureux de souhaiter la
bienvenue à madame nathalie porte devenu
député de la 3e circonscription du
calvados le 28 juillet en remplacement
de monsieur sébastien lepert chers
collègues vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
les dernières avancées de la recherche
nous font espérer la mise en service
très prochaine d'un vaccin efficace
contre la copie de 19
ce vaccin nous permettrait de voir le
bout du tunnel de cette crise sanitaire
si éprouvante pour les français l'espoir
d'un vaccin c'est l'espoir d'enrayer
cette épidémie qui a fait déjà plus de
40 mille morts sur le sol français
c'est l'espoir de désengorger des épées
de les hôpitaux français où comme à
lisieux on doit renvoyer des patients
chez eux pour prendre en charge des
malades du cog vide c'est surtout
l'espoir que ce confinement soit le
dernier que des milliers de petites et
moyennes entreprises puissent enfin
reprendre une activité normale et que
les commerçants que vous considérez
comme un non essentiels puisse rouvrir
mais encore faut-il que le gouvernement
soit capable de relever le défi en
commandant en stockant et en acheminant
ces vaccins en très grand nombre
dans un contexte de forte concurrence
internationale l'anticipation sera
fondamental le vaccin n'est pas encore
disponible mais la stratégie
d'approvisionnement se décide se mette
en oeuvre maintenant après le manque
criant de masques en mars
le manque criant de tests en avril il
serait incompréhensible que notre pays
sixième puissance mondiale
manque de vaccins contre lacko vide nous
sommes d'autant plus inquiet que votre
campagne actuelle de vaccination contre
la grippe saisonnière est un fiasco
nous sommes en situation de grave
pénurie et même les soignants ne peuvent
souvent pas se faire tous vaccinés
contre la grippe
j'ai deux questions simples avez vous
anticipez une stratégie
d'approvisionnement en vaccins contre la
coved et pouvez vous garantir que les
français et en priorité les soignants
n'auront pas à souffrir d'une pénurie de
ces vaccins je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur adrien taquet secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre des solidarités de la
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
ne commençons pas cette première prise
de parole par des polémiques inutiles ne
faisons pas de polémique sur un vaccin
qui n'est pas encore trouvée ne fait pas
de polémique sur la campagne de
vaccination contre la grippe qui a été
un succès cette année
jamais autant les français ne se sont
vaccinés contre la grippe est en
priorité les personnes les plus
vulnérables
vous devriez vous en réjouir madame la
députée sur le fond de vote sur le fond
de votre question sur le fond de votre
question je vous rejoins sur le fait que
les annonces faites par le laboratoire
pfizer hier son parts d'un certain
nombre d'espoirs il faut garder
néanmoins une très grande prudence
nous n'en somme ils n'en sont qu'à la
phase iii des tests l'élaboration de ce
vaccin je l' ai dit tout à l'heure il y
a encore au moins un mois de tests
nécessaires avant que les autorités
sanitaires américaines et européennes
puisse se saisir des datas disponibles
et envisager la délivrance de
l'autorisation
en parallèle je l'évoquais tout à
l'heure si vous m'aviez écoutez vous ne
me reposerai pas la question monsieur le
député la haute autorité de santé est en
train de travailler à l'élaboration des
recommandations qui nous permettront de
fixer la politique de vaccination qui
devra également tenir compte du profil
spécifique de chaque vaccin et de leur
disponibilité puisque vous le savez
plusieurs laboratoires sont en train de
développer ce qu'on fasse plutôt bien
avancé de réalisation de vaccins qui
n'ont pas tous les mêmes
caractéristiques à deux doses pour
certains à une dose pour d'autres
enfin madame la députée la question de
la stratégie d'approvisionnement ne
commence pas maintenant
elle a commencé il ya déjà plusieurs
mois dans le cadre européen
sous l'impulsion de la france la france
a commandé auprès de l'europe a commandé
par don auprès de pfizer 200 millions de
doses plus 100 millions en option il ya
eu de pré commandes qui ont été
effectuées à la tension en direction
d'autres d'autres laboratoires je pense
à astrazeneca notamment la stratégie est
donc en cours depuis de nombreuses
semaines de nombreux mois je peux vous
rassurer que l'ensemble des français
pourront avoir accès à ce vaccin dans le
cadre des recommandations de la haute
autorité de santé jour même merci
monsieur le maire
la parole est à monsieur jean-paul 4
secondes ça va être dense cette année
allez-y 7
ces polémiques parce que cela vous
dérange mais c'est l'avis de tous les
français
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues la parole s'il
vous plaît à monsieur jean paul matte et
à lui seul ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre délégué à l'industrie
madame la ministre nous avons voté en
séance le 27 octobre dernier
le plan de relance de 100 milliards dont
22 milliards seront débloqués dès 2021
ces trois grands volets préparant
l'avenir 30 milliards d'euros pour la
transition écologique 34 milliard
d'euros pour la compétitivité la
souveraineté économique et 36 milliards
d'euros pour la cohésion sociale et
territoriale
si l'effet coup de poing de ce plan de
relance est recherché par sa rapidité
il doit aussi s'accompagner de pédagogie
sur le terrain et de financer des
projets structurels à long terme
je sais que le gouvernement dès le 13
octobre lancé le recrutement de 30 sous
préfet à la relance avant d'accompagner
les citoyens les entreprises et les nuls
vous nous avez également indiqué que les
crédits serait piloté depuis bercy en
lien avec les différents ministères vous
nous avez déjà annoncé que ce plan
pourrait se voir abondé d'ici la seconde
lecture du plf à l'assemblée pour parer
or confinement seule la clarté de la
répartition des rôles entre tous les
acteurs qui participent à sa mise en
oeuvre sera garante de son efficacité
et j'avoue que je ne suis pas convaincu
par la fluidité du processus décisionnel
aussi madame la ministre pouvait nous
pouvez vous nous préciser comment sera
traité à compter du 1er janvier prochain
l'infection des crédits de la relance
aux différents de vendeurs quels acteurs
seront les relais nationaux régionaux et
locaux
comment seront sélectionnés les
bénéficiaires de ces crédits je ne peux
que vous suggérez d'étoffé ce dispositif
en y associant la représentation
nationale auprès de qui nos concitoyens
font remonter les difficultés qu'ils
rencontrent et cela de manière active et
non pas en tant que simple invité je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole à
madame agnès ministre délégué chargé de
la juste
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
mathijs l'indiqué à main ce temps bruno
le maire est précisément en train de
présider un comité de pilotage sur le
plan de relance car le plan de relance
c'est maintenant un certain nombre de
dispositifs je pense notamment au
dispositif puissant en matière
d'accompagnement de l'emploi des jeunes
un jeune une formation en matière
d'activité partielle de longue durée en
matière d'accompagnement dans l'emploi
des handicapés sont d'ores et déjà en
place dans notre pays ce qui nous
permettra dès la fin de l'année de
d'engager près de 10 milliards d'euros
de soutien à l'emploi à l'industrie aux
entreprises pour aider à leur
transformation et à passer ce cap
difficile
comment cela se passe-t-il très
concrètement il ya quatre types de
dispositifs des dispositifs de guiche
des dispositifs automatiques
la baisse des impôts de production par
exemple dont bénéficie automatiquement
les entreprises ou les français sur le
territoire l'important c'est de les
faire connaître et de les expliciter
deuxième type de dispositif les
dispositifs de guichet je prends ma
prime rénove par exemple qui est d'ores
et déjà également en place vous êtes
vous souhaitez faire rénover votre
maison pour des raisons de rénovation
thermique vous avez d'ores et déjà tous
les éléments sur le site plan de relance
point gouv.fr et vous êtes guidé pour
pouvoir bénéficier de ses soutiens
je peux citer dans le lait guichet la
prime à la conversion pour les à
l'automobile
l'aide aux mères densifie catr donc
c'est également pour les collectivités
locales ou les aide à la numérisation et
la décarbonation qui sont d'ores et déjà
en place de manière extrêmement simple
troisième type de guide de mesures les
mesures des concentrés dans la main des
préfets qui dans le cadre de comités
pilotage qui ont vocation à vous
associer qui ont vocation à vos associés
permettront de répondre au problème
enfin des appels à projets qui sont
d'ores et déjà lancées dans l'industrie
la transition énergétique l'agriculture
c'est une instruction pour des raisons
d'égal accès à ces dispositifs qui est
reconcentrer avec un fils de décisions
qui sont en train de tomber
nous sommes très bien engagé sur ce plan
de relance
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur nicolas maisonnée merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre au ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre
267 c'est le nombre de personnes qui ont
péri des mains de barbarie islamiste en
france depuis 2012 et le nom de compte
plus les blessés tant ils sont nombreux
540 c'est le nombre de mosquées radical
en france où l'on prêche la haine chaque
jour en toute impunité
22000 c'est le nombre d'individus fiché
pour islam is who est experte et qui
circulent sur notre sol parmi eux 4 me
sens sont étrangers 26 c'est le nombre
dérisoire de clandestins islamistes que
vous avez raccompagner à la frontière
depuis l'assassinât de sa mère pattie 26
seulement en trois semaines ces chiffres
montrent que le sentier entreprendre
impérativement en matière de lutte
contre le terrorisme islamiste est au
point mort et ce malgré toutes vos
agitation médiatique
combien y aura-t-il fallu deux victimes
ces derniers jouent encore à conflans
sainte honorine à nice pour que le
président de la république concède enfin
timidement qu'il pourrait y avoir un
lien entre cette barbarie et
l'immigration
un microscopique progrès monsieur le
ministre il est temps d'agir
qu'attendez vous pour lutter contre ces
associations subventionnées notamment
par l'union européenne qui vont chercher
en mer des milliers de pseudo réfugiés
et les déverse sur nos côtes en toute
illégalité
qu'attendez vous pour déclarer que pas
un seul djihadistes ne reviendra sur les
territoires français ni d'irak ni de
syrie ni de libye contrairement aux
souhaits de votre collègue garde des
sceaux qu'attendez vous pour dissoudre
l'uojf branche des frères musulmans en
france organisation que par exemple
l'egypte et les émirats arabes unis ont
classé comme terroriste
qu'attendez vous pour expulser les 4000
fichier s étrangers susceptibles de
circuler en france dont près du quart
sont de surcroît sans titre de séjour
qu'attendez vous pour frapper
d'indignité nationale les nationaux et
déchoir de leur nationalité les
binationaux qui pactisent avec l'ennemi
qu'attendez vous pour mettre un terme à
cette politique folle d'immigration
massive légales et illégales qui
constituent le terreau sur lequel
prospère cette idéologie macabre
merci la parole est à monsieur gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur le
président l'un de ces députés monsieur
débuté le 1er avec la démagogie c'est
qu'elle n'a pas de limites quand on
commence à aller dedans
monsieur maisonnée ce que vous dites est
assez grave
ce que vous dites monsieur mais d'assez
rare pour qu'on puisse y ait au moins
évité de mentir sur les chiffres que
j'ai maintes fois répété dans cet
hémicycle en commission des lois est
quand même à l'extérieur lorsque vous
écoutez sans doute la télévision
monsieur le député vous dites 22000
personnes qui sont fichés s vous ne
suivez pas les débats parlementaires
22000 c'est le nombre de fiches depuis
que la création du ffs pertes et a été
fait d'ailleurs c'est bien le présent
m'a conquis le premier à connecter ce
fichier avec sedan des préfectures pour
faire un réseau national le nombre de
fiches active c8000 ce n'est pas 22
milles entre 8000 et 22000 hume il s'est
déjà beaucoup monsieur le député mais ce
n'est pas la peine de réitérer un
mensonge pour qu'ils deviennent vérité
dans la bouche de voeux aux
parlementaires
la deuxième des choses vite 4100
étrangers j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
la semaine dernière cet hémicycle
peut-être me suis-je man exprimés ou
peut-être n'avez-vous pas tout à fait
suivi la réponse que j'ai pu faire au
député ciotti 4000 personnes étrangères
qui sont effectivement ofs pertes et
cela comprend surtout les étrangers qui
sont à l'étranger et que nous on parvint
revenir sur le territoire national sepa
26 somme de personnes que nous avons
expulsé monsieur le député c'est plus de
450 depuis te présente la république est
présent la république et je suis capable
de vous dire monsieur le député je
répondrai à toutes vos questions
évidemment si à partir du moment où on a
des vrais chiffres auxquels on peut
vraiment discuté le vrai sujet le vrai
sujet monsieur députés et ça je pense
qu'effectivement ça de vous faire un
petit peu mal à votre fond de commerce
électoral c'est que nous agissons et que
nous rassurons les français
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame sylvie tall man l'école est un
lieu d'instruction et de socialisation
est essentielle pour notre jeunesse
c'est pourquoi au regard des situations
de décrochage lors du premier
confinement le groupe socialiste a
soutenu le maintien de l'ouverture des
établissements scolaires sous condition
de leur adaptation total au contexte
sanitaire
après dix jours de confinement nationale
vous avez finalement décidé la mise en
place d'un enseignement hybride dans les
lycées tout en écartant cette
possibilité pour les collèges au motif
d'une densité d'une circulation des
élèves moins forte
or les brassages au moment des entrées
et des sorties dans les couloirs comme à
la cantine sans pourtant tout aussi
problématique
le 26 octobre dernier le conseil
scientifique déclaré je cite les
adolescents de 12 à 18 ans semblait
avoir la même susceptibilité aux virus
et la même contagiosité vers leur
entourage que les adultes il ya quatre
jours vous présentiez des chiffres
rassurants de l'épidémie en milieu soupe
scolaire avec 3500 28 élèves testés
positifs des chiffres pourtant très
éloignée des données de santé publique
france faisant état de 25 mille contrôle
positif chez les 0 19 ans entre le 4 et
le entre le 2 et le 4 novembre
vos données ne traduisent donc pas la
dynamique épidémique laissant croire à 6
à une contamination maîtriser alors
qu'un plan de continuité pédagogique
préparer dès juillet prévoyant le
passage à 16 ans tess enseignement
hybride en cas de circulation active du
virus aurait pu être activée plutôt se
développe à nouveau un sentiment
d'improvisation dans l'urgence
extrêmement anxiogène pour les élèves
leurs familles et les personnels
telle est d'ailleurs le sens du
mouvement qui se développe dans les
établissements aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre que proposez vous pour prendre
en compte la situation collège au dollar
et au risque de me répéter depuis le
printemps dernier quels moyens humains
et matériels humains et matériels allez
vous enfin déployés pour garantir une
continuité pédagogique plus efficace que
lors du premier confinement à tous les
élèves au delà que proposez-vous pour
favoriser et sécuriser l'accès aux
cantines essentiel pour les enfants les
plus défavorisés
merci jean michel blanquer ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
des sports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
sylvie toronto le monde quand j'écoute
votre question en réalité je pense qu'on
pourrait assez facilement et rend
d'accord sur beaucoup de choses parce
que les objectifs que vous avez fixé
c'est les nôtres c'est que les élèves
ait à l'école et l'objectif de sécurité
sanitaire c'est évidemment le nôtre je
me souviens de débats et de question que
nous avons eu dans la période allant de
mars à juin et où il y avait beaucoup de
reproches aussi à cette époque notamment
sur le décrochage et bien j'ai une bonne
nouvelle à vous annoncer je suis sûr
qu'elle vous fera plaisir c'est que on
vient la voir l' enquête il ya eu moins
de décrocheurs en 2020 qu'en 2019
ça n'est pas rien ça doit réjouir tout
le pays
ça veut dire que nos dispositifs ont
fonctionné alors vous m'interrogez sur
la question de finalement les moyens que
nous déployons actuellement d'abord je
voudrais redire ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire nous avons un
cursus un curseur nous le faisons
évoluer en fonction de la situation
sanitaire et c'est tout à fait vrai que
mon but est que les élèves aillent le
plus possible à l'école je le confesse
si c'est mal il faut me le dire mais moi
je cherche à ce que les élèves puissent
aller à l'école au maximum parce que
quand ils n'y vont pas c'est mauvais
pour alors est ce que nous sommes prêts
à assouplir davantage
enfin durcir davantage le protocole pour
qu'ils puissent éventuellement assurer -
de brassage des élèves contrairement à
ce que vous avez dit au collège ya quand
même moins de brassage qu'au lycée pour
des raisons évidentes et en plus les
élèves n'ont pas le même âge donc chacun
comprend que les mesures ne sont pas les
mêmes au collège qu'au lycée nous avons
accordé certaine souplesse a dès le
collège particulièrement dense
nous le faisons que par exception parce
que dans la plupart des cas on arrive à
assurer le nom brassage des élèves
nous restons ouverts sur l'avenir en
fonction de l'évolution de l'épidémie
mais à chaque fois c'est un équilibre
entre le retour des élèves
et là le protocole sanitaire s'agissant
des moyens nous avons acheté encore
récemment six mille ordinateurs que nous
sommes capables de distribuer je vous
rappelle que nous fermons régulièrement
des écoles des collèges et des lycées
dès qu'il y à des cas avérés et dans ces
moments là nous faisons cela
actuellement des départements comme le
val d'oise ou laine bénéficie par
exemple d'un autre plan 100%
informatique et le député bricout le
souligne à juste titre
votre groupe merci et bien donc oui nous
avançons nous avons sont aussi sur la
formation des professeurs et donc j'en
parlerai ultérieurement mais cette
préparation là existe aussi la parole
est à madame béatrice piron merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur jean michel
blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale et j'y associe le président de
la commission des affaires culturelles
éducation bruno stud air ainsi que mes
collègues du groupe de travail numérique
éducatif
monsieur le ministre le recours au
numérique pour assurer la continuité
pédagogique a globalement été une
réussite grâce à la mobilisation des
professeurs mais aussi des parents
toutefois il a aussi révélé les défis
auxquels éducation nationale fait face
pour mettre numérique au service des
besoins éducatifs
comment garantir l'accès au numérique
partout et pour tous comment enseigner
avec le numérique
comment reprendre l'art souvenirs unités
sur nos outils des députés de notre
groupe vous ont fait par monsieur
ministre de 15 propositions pour
construire au numérique éducatif de
demain dont par exemple
l'homogénéisation à l'échelle nationale
des outils de vie scolaire notamment aux
primaires ou la clarification de la
politique d'équipement des élèves
partagée entre l'état et les
collectivités territoriales
vous avez organisé les états généraux du
numérique dont les conclusions se sont
tenues la semaine dernière aboutissant à
40 propositions certaines déjà retenu
comme la création d'un data club
éducation et la prime d'équipements pour
les enseignants permettre à chacun de
maîtriser les compétences numériques est
indispensable dans un monde en pleine
révolution d'autant plus en période de
crise sanitaire maintenir les écoles
ouvertes est fondamental pour préserver
l'éducation des jeunes générations
dwan cela doit se faire en respectant
les protocoles sanitaires renforcés mais
aussi en développant de nouvelles façons
d'enseigner
comme c'est le cas au lycée vous avez
proposé de mettre en place un
enseignement hybride
ainsi monsieur le ministre quels seront
le calendrier et la méthode pour la mise
en oeuvre des propositions issues des
états généraux ou celle de notre groupe
quels moyens allez vous donner à l'est
du canal écoles pour affronter les défis
de la fracture numérique et de la
souveraineté sur les outils dans un
contexte sanitaire où cela devient un
instrument indispensable à la réussite
de nos élèves
je remercie
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur jean michel blanquer ministre
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
et des sports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
béatrice piron je vous remercie pour
cette question sur un sujet très
important et d'actualité
je remercie aussi présidence tuner pour
sa collaboration aux états généraux du
numérique et plus généralement pour ces
travaux d'ailleurs sur sur le sujet et
puis aussi à certains de mes collègues
du gouvernement qui ont participé à ces
états généraux du numérique comme amélie
de montchanin sur les sujets fonction
publique le sujet a considérablement
avancé grâce aux états généraux d'abord
parce qu'il ya eu des milliers de
participants en amont et c'est ce que
nous attendions c'était la première
étape du grenelle de l'éducation c'est à
souligner aussi parce que ça fait partie
du bien-être professionnelle des
enseignants que de pouvoir avoir un bon
contexte informatique cela passe par
plusieurs aspects ya un aspect de
protection de nos élèves
je pense à ce qui a été dit en matière
de données personnelles je pense à ce
qui a été dit en matière de cyber
harcèlement par exemple et puis un
aspect d'ambition pour nos élèves de ce
côté là il ya plusieurs sujets il ya
notre capacité à + équipe et je le
disais tout à l'heure dans la précédente
réponse nous avons acquis six mille
ordinateurs récemment nous connaîtrons
continuerons à le faire pour la période
actuelle
mais surtout nous allons continuer à
développer des dispositifs qui vaudront
même après la pandémie
je pense à une idée qui est venue des
états généraux ce qu'on appelle y de
voir fait c'est à dire faire les aider à
faire les devoirs mais aussi à distance
d'ailleurs pendant les vacances de
printemps nous avions eu de belles
expérimentation en la matière je pense
aussi à tout ce qui est fait aujourd'hui
pour accompagner les enseignants en
matière de formation sur l'enseignement
à distance
notre institution canopée a ainsi formé
cent mille enseignants pendant la
période récente à distance nous allons
continuer dans cette direction et les
états généraux du numérique vont être
prolongées par ce qui se dira dans le
grenelle par toute une série de
dispositifs concrets
j'en profite pour dire que notre projet
poitiers capital de l'éducation continue
dans ce sens avec nos opérateurs
le cned canopée l'institut des hautes
études de formation et d'autres acteurs
du numérique pour que la france soit à
l'avant-garde desertec et des enjeux du
numérique de l'éducation je vous
remercie
merci monsieur
la parole est à monsieur eric dire merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale
monsieur le ministre vous êtes un
fervent défenseur des valeurs de la
république et je me dois de vous donner
en tant que député certaines
informations et je reste à votre
disposition sur ce sujet vendredi
vous avez déclaré qu'il y a eu 400
signalement environ 400 signalements
concernant des violations à l'hommage de
samuel pâtit je pense que ce chiffre ne
correspond pas à la réalité est peut
être êtes vous de cet avis au lendemain
de ce tragique assassinat un quotidien
attitré les enseignants ont brisé
l'omerta et je peux vous dire qu'il y à
des établissements qui n'ont pas fait
l'hommage pour ne pas avoir de troubles
internes
enfin je peux vous parler d'un lycée
professionnel où les personnes de sexe
masculin ne déjeune qu'entre elle et ne
sert plus la main aux personnes du sexe
opposé
et ce bien avant la période du coc vide
le plus grave
monsieur le ministre c'est qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'élèves et d'enseignants
je tiens à vous dire que malheureusement
les atteintes à la laïcité le
communautarisme ont gangréné certaines
écoles certains collèges certains lycées
aussi monsieur le ministre
quelles mesures comptez-vous prendre
lors de la loi sur le séparatisme pour
les éradiquer
je vous remercie
merci monsieur de député la parade est à
monsieur jean michel blanquer venus
dédicacer nationale de la jeunesse et
des sports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
eric garde le sujet que vous abordez est
évidemment essentielle et nous avons des
principes d'action dont vous pouvez vous
pourrez vérifier qu'ils accomplissent
pour le passé le présent et le futur nos
principes d'action d'abord c'est des
normes claires
ces normes sont fixés par notre conseil
des sages de la laïcité et bien sûr
certaines des choses que vous avez cités
sont en contravention de ces normes
claires donc tout faits signalés et vous
avez tout à fait le droit de me les
signaler
bien entendu aura des suites par rapport
à ces normes claires nous avons les
équipes valeurs de la république
elles interviennent encore en ce moment
aujourd'hui même par exemple ensuite des
400 violations dont nous dont j'ai parlé
et bien entendu s'il ya plus que ces 400
violations signalées les le signalement
est encore ouvert évidemment mais j'ai
été très clair la minute de silence doit
être partout sans exception et chaque
violation doit être signalé j'ai la
liste des violations si ce que vous avez
vu ne correspond pas on ajoutera et on
réagira donc je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya
pas de problème bien sûr qu'il ya des
problèmes
simplement nous sommes très clairs sur
les règles et nous sommes très clair que
sur le fait que à la fin force doit être
à la république et au droit donc je vous
invite à me signaler les cas qu
éventuellement nous aurait échappé c'est
ça peut être possible je ne dis pas le
contraire mais en tout état de cause
nous avons déjà déployé les équipes
valeurs de la république
chaque fois qu'un signalement nous a été
fait nous avons nous avons agi et bien
sûr les faits que vous signalez ne sont
pas acceptables
dès lors qu'ils sont avérées je tiens à
vous dire parce que c'est des choses que
on dit pas forcément tous les jours et
publiquement mais que nous avons procédé
par exemple à des radiations de
personnel radicaliser et que j'y ai
veillé personnellement et que bien
entendu chacun doit respecter les règles
de la fonction publique dans l'exercice
de son métier
et s'agissant des élèves il ya toujours
un travail éducatif qui est fait
évidemment un travail aussi de
discussions avec les familles c'est
exactement ce que l'on est en train de
boire de ce moment à la suite des
incidents qui ont pu avoir lieu donc
notre détermination est totale notre
ouverture et total aussi s'y aventure
vous considérez qu'il ya des choses qui
n'ont pas été signalés pour merci merci
je dire merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre il est important dans la loi
sur le séparatisme que soient prises des
mesures fortes
il en est de la survie de l'école de la
république
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur le président andré chassaigne
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre notre pays
est à nouveau confiné pour tenter
d'enrayer une épidémie qui met sous
pression notre système hospitalier
cette mesure pour freiner les
contaminations ne doit pas nous faire
oublier les considérables dégâts sociaux
économiques qu'elle engendre vos
dispositifs de soutien sont insuffisants
ils sont insuffisants pour juguler le
chômage la pauvreté les inégalités
sociales
nous refusons un confinement libéral
doux pour les puissants dur pour les
petits la solidarité doit s'exprimer
pour toutes les victimes de cette crise
sanitaire en faisant plus pour le
million de personnes pauvres
supplémentaires plus en particulier pour
les jeunes précaires et les étudiants en
faisant plus pour les milliers de
travailleurs qui vont perdre leur emploi
plus aussi pour les salariés en chômage
partiel qui perd 2 16% de leurs salaires
en faisant plus pour les petits
commerçants et les indépendants qui
subissent de plein fouet le confinement
chaque mesure de restriction prises dans
le cas de la gestion sanitaire doit être
conditionnée à de puissantes mesures
d'accompagnement social et économique
à défaut ce sont les français notamment
les plus modestes qui en paieront le
prix
pour éviter cela allez vous retirer
votre réforme de l'assurance chômage qui
conduit à baisser les allocations des
privés d'emploi allez-vous prévoir une
prise en charge du chômage partiel à
100% du salaire
allez vous augmenter les minima sociaux
et aider les associations fortement
terriblement sollicité à faire face aux
urgences
allez-vous faute de revenus l'autonomie
élargir le champ du rsa pour les jeunes
allez-vous compenser toutes les paires
de chiffre d'affaires des petits
commerçants allez vous enfin enfin
mettre à contribution les gars femmes et
les assurances
six questions six questions seulement
mais qui atteint des réponses précises
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur présent chassaigne vous
soulevez évidemment une question
fondamentale qui est celle des dégâts
commis par la crise économique et
sociale elle-même fille de la crise
sanitaire question qui mobilise
complètement je vous le dis et la
majorité et le gouvernement de la
république trois données chiffrées
monsieur le président pour vous répondre
d'emblée de manière précise il y a trois
semaines le président de la république
annonçait le déblocage pour les publics
vulnérables pour le public pauvres de 1
milliard quatre cent mille euros 150
euros pour revaloriser le rsa et pour
les bénéficiaires du rsa et de la ss
plus 100 euros par enfant
150 euros pour les jeunes qui sont aux
apl
c'est à dire quatre cent mille et des
aides d'un même montant pour les
éditions précaire versées par les crous
création de 1500 places d'hébergement
notamment destiné aux femmes seules avec
enfants 1500 places dans des logements
très précaire pnj plus des aides aux
associations caritatives qu'à votre
suite
je veux tout à fait félicitées pour leur
action absolument indispensable est
remarquable dans la période très grave
que notre pays traverse
nous les soutenons 1,4 milliard d'euros
deuxième chiffre 1,8 milliard d'euros
il est issu du plan de relance nous
avons revaloriser l'allocation de
rentrée scolaire à hauteur de 100 euros
et nous avons prévu des moyens massifs
pour l'insertion des jeunes en
difficulté dans le plan un jeune une
solution enfin 20 milliards d'euros
c'est le montant du plfr numéro 4
monsieur le président qui va être
bientôt débattu ici
qui gêne qui prolonge de l'activité
partielle en particulier tous les
smicards se rassemblent pour cent de
leur salaire je vous rappelle mais vous
le savez qui accroît dans des conditions
considérable l'aide à l'économie en
particulier aux commerces de proximité
tout ça tout ça monsieur le président
nous conduira je le rappelle à
l'assemblée nationale un déficit public
de 11,3 pour cent du pib
vous avez parlé monsieur le président
d'un confinement libéral convenu que
nous sommes très loin d'un libéralisme
échevelé
au contraire l'état se mobilise l'état
investit massivement mais je dois vous
répondre qu'effectivement il le fait
dans le cadre de la philosophie qui a
toujours été celle de cette majorité
pour lutter contre la pauvreté
non pas en augmentant structurellement
les minima sociaux en venant au secours
des plus vulnérables comme c'est le cas
en ce moment et surtout en leur
proposant des solutions pour sortir de
la pauvreté pour se former pour
s'insérer pour s'affranchir
je rappelle notamment que pour l'iae
nous avons débloqué 30 mille postes
supplémentaires que dans le cadre du
plan pour les jeunes
porté par la ministre du travail il y a
trois cent mille formation dédiée aux
publics éloignés de l'emploi avec des
parcours sur mesure et qu'enfin nous
avons multiplié les parcours emploi
compétences dans les quartiers de la
politique de la ville et les zones de
revitalisation rurale avec un taux de
prise en charge par l'état de 80% ce
sont des actions massives pour lutter
contre la pauvreté et ses dégâts dus à
la crise sanitaire et économique et le
gouvernement entend bien poursuivre dans
cette voie je vous remercie
monsieur le premier ministre la parole
est à monsieur pierre yves bournazel
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères il y a dix ans le
ministre des affaires étrangères turc
utilisé une formule pacifique
pour résumer les ambitions stratégiques
de son pays zéro problème avec les
voisins depuis en syrie en irak à chypre
dans les eaux grecques de la
méditerranée orientale en libye est
dorénavant dans le sud caucase où elle
intervient en appui de l'azerbaïdjan la
turquie manoeuvre sur six terrains
d'opérations dans le même temps le
régime d'erdogan choisi d'aider
notamment les financent en partie et
mouvance idéologiquement proche de lui
essentiellement les frères musulmans le
président erdogan a récemment insulté la
france et le président de la république
le président azerbaïdjanais aliyev a
déclaré ce jour à propos des arméniens
je le cite
j'avais dit qu'on les chasse frais de
notaire comme des chiens et nous l'avons
fait soyons lucides
l'histoire s'accélère nous ne pouvons
pas accepter ce qui vient de se passer
il ne s'agit pas de confondre
l'agressivité du régime erdogan avec son
peuple
issu d'une grande culture qui en subit
lui-même les méfaits mais
l'expansionnisme néo ottoman a
aujourd'hui débordé du cadre
géopolitique pour agir en france à
travers les activités du mouvement
ultra-nationaliste des loups gris
dissous depuis la semaine dernière
nous souhaitons un message fort un
message fort de soutien envers nos amis
arméniens
alors qu'hier en accord de cessez le feu
total sous l'égide de la russie a été
signé avec l'azerbaïdjan avec des
collègues parlementaires et à
l'initiative de françois pupponi de guy
teissier
nous avons signé il ya plusieurs jours
une proposition de résolution sur la
reconnaissance de la république
d'artsakh l'europe et l'otan doivent se
faire entendre
monsieur le ministre quelle marque de
soutien voorn pays peut-il apporter à
l'arménie et quelle réponse diplomatique
ferme apporter aux néo impérialisme
turcs je vous remercie aussi le sait les
buts et la parole comme suit jean yves
le drian
des mauvaises affaires étrangères c'est
le député bournazel je me suis exprimé
déjà plusieurs reprises sur le
comportement belliqueux et insupportable
de la turquie ici dans cette assemblée
vous avez rappelé la liste de six
terrains de confrontation et de dents
grande de spirale dangereuse de
confrontations que mène ce pays 2 sur
l'environnement européen est en
méditerranée il a eu en plus je le dis
ici parce que je les dis aussi à
plusieurs reprises publiquement un saut
qualitatif au delà de ce que vous venez
de dire lorsque le président erdogan
appelle à la haine contre notre pays
lorsque le président ado gagnent insulte
les valeurs qui fondent notre nation
nous sommes passés à une étape
supplémentaire il ya eu un saut
qualitatif majeur et j'ai bien noté que
récemment il y avait eu de la part des
autorités turques la condamnation des
attentats de nice et de vienne mais nous
attendons des clarifications majeur sur
les deux registres sur le premier
registre qu'il y ait des discours de la
part des autorités turques qui remettent
en cause ce qui a été dit annoncées
contre la france pour traiter la france
deux nations islamophobe mais sur les
enjeux de confrontation lya un
rendez-vous qui est connue qui est le
mode décembre à bruxelles les vingt-sept
ont décidé que si la turquie ne
changeait pas de posture
alors il y aurait des mesures de prise à
son encontre y compris des sanctions cas
tout est sur la table et sur l'accord et
sur l'accord qui s'est passé hier
n'aurait pas le temps de commenter
longuement ce qui s'est passé cette nuit
mais concernant la turquie nous
considérons que il importe de manière
très claire que la turquie respecte
c'est celle qui est passé parce que
sinon elle se mettrait en danger
d'aggravation d'extinction qui pourrait
apporter contre elle
merci la parole est à monsieur xavier
breton
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre je voudrais avec mes
collègues de la damien abad et charles
de la verpillière vous alerter sur les
graves événements qui ont eu lieu ce
week-end dans notre département dans les
villes d'oyonnax et de bourg-en-bresse
tirs de mortiers jets de cocktails
molotov véhicules brûlés c'est une
véritable flambée de violences qui a
embrasé des quartiers de ces villes face
à ces scènes de violences urbaines
saluons d'abord le courage des forces de
sécurité agressés harceler les ont su
faire face et ramener le calme
nous exprimons notre soutien aux
policiers nationaux et municipaux qui
ont été blessés par des tirs de
projectiles soutient également aux
sapeurs pompiers qui sont intervenus
dans des conditions extrêmement
périlleuse monsieur le premier ministre
donc aux citoyens sont aujourd'hui
exaspérés alors qu'ils doivent supporter
les contraintes du confinement qui
restreignent leurs activités et leurs
libertés
le compatriote subissent ces violences
d'une minorité de jeunes délinquants qui
polluent leur quotidien et saccagent
impunément leur cadre de vie
non nous n'avons pas affaire à des
incivilités nous avons affaire à des
délits des délits particulièrement
violent dans le but de dégrader de
casser de blessés face à ces scènes
inadmissible nos concitoyens attendent
des réponses fermes rapide et déterminée
ils attendent des actes et non des
discours et au delà de bourg-en-bresse
et d'oyonnax ce sont aujourd'hui
beaucoup de villes françaises qui
subissent ces flambées de violence
notamment des villes moyennes ce qui est
un signal inquiétant pour notre pays
alors monsieur le premier ministre
qu'allez vous faire concrètement et
rapidement pour ramener durablement le
calme dans nos villes qu'allez vous
faire concrètement et rapidement pour
lutter contre cette délinquance qui
empoisonnent la vie de nos concitoyens
merci monsieur le député la parole est
un monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le président
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
breton
effectivement les violences qui ont eu
lieu dans le département de l'ain et
dans certaines communes de ce
département de l'ain c'est le cas de
yona ces cas de bourg-en-bresse
d'autres communes sont tout à fait
inacceptables
et dès les premières heures puisque des
policiers nationaux devant sécuriser
l'arrivée des sapeurs pompiers
devant une cinquantaine 70 individus
difficile de dénombrer mail enquête est
en cours
j'ai fait demander à la préfète d'abord
de prendre contact avec les élus
elle a appelé me semble-t-il de
président à bague je vais saluer parce
qu'il m'a comme vous interpellez de
cette violence est dépêché des forces
par le directeur général de la police
nationale pour qu en nombre le calme
soit rétabli ce qui a été le fait vous
savez en week end après des forces de
police nombreuses et trois policiers
blessés dont moi aussi je voudrais
saluer qu'ils soient municipaux des
gendarmes ou des policiers nationaux
le courage pour avoir rétabli
effectivement l'ordre républicain
je voudrais souligner monsieur le député
breton que les enquêtes sont en cours et
qu'il ne faut pas désespérer ses
enquêtes
plus question ne sont posés sur le drame
de champigny sur marne où ce
commissariat avait été attaqué je sais
qu'il ya eu des interpellations
nombreuses et que des enquêtes qui ont
été poursuivis par le procureur de la
république avec la préfecture de police
de paris a permis de confondre ces
délinquants et je l'espère de les
condamner fermement dans les prochains
temps ce sera le cas dans les nuits que
nous avons connue et qui ont fait naître
des incendies de véhicules 7 et aussi
des feux de poubelles et des jets de
projectiles sur les pompiers et sur les
policiers des forces supplémentaires
sont aujourd'hui dans le département de
l'ain
structurellement le départ cela doit
connaître singulièrement dans les villes
moyennes c'est d'oyonnax celle de
bourg-en-bresse
monsieur le député abad m'a interpellé
je lui répondrais président positivement
pour que les effectifs supplémentaires
grâce notamment à ceux qui ont été créés
par le par le parlement depuis trois ans
grâce au président de la république mais
aussi je voudrais le dire sur
l'interdiction des feux de mortier et
feu d'artifice et pour cela monsieur le
député des 18 novembre
que faire
voter la proposition de loi ne fait rien
même tour aux nous aurons interdit et
pénaliser la vente et l'utilisation de
ces feux d'artifice merci monsieur le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président simplement
monsieur le médiateur
on entend le travail qui est fait au
niveau des interpellations il convient
aussi que ce soit au niveau judiciaire
qu'il y ait des réponses encore une fois
nous n'attendons pas des discours mais
bien des actes merci show collègues
la parole est à monsieur bruno fuchs
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la guinée et la côte d'ivoire
viennent d'élire leur président pour un
troisième mandat
cette élection contestée pour a boycotté
par les oppositions pour des atteintes
graves à la démocratie des candidatures
ont été empêchés de multiples manières
des résultats eux-mêmes ne sont pas
certains pendant que les pouvoirs et les
opposition se renvoient la balle
ces deux pays menacent de s'enfoncer
jour après jour dans la violence faisant
craindre le pire pour des populations
qui sont les otages de ces désordres
constitutionnel pour la côte d'ivoire la
haut commissaire aux droits de l'homme
mme michelle bachelet s'est montré très
préoccupé par l'état du pays
la voix de la france est entendue et
attendu par nos partenaires ils
connaissent notre engagement mais aussi
notre exigence comme le président de la
république l'a rappelé récemment au
liban
la voix de la france compte elle s'est
bâtie autour de valeurs et de principes
auxquels nous ne pouvons d'hergé et pour
lesquels nous nous battons la liberté la
démocratie le pluralisme sont de ceux là
la voix de la france compte par sa
diplomatie française et ses politiques
de coopération ambitieuse et renforcer
dans ce contexte le trouble autres pays
a évidemment un rôle majeur à jouer dans
l'issue qui sera trouvé à ces conflits
comme il a su le faire en 2003 lors des
accords de marcoussis
monsieur le ministre nous savons et
saluons votre engagement sur ces sujets
leur dernière prise de parole au niger
ou voudrais féliciter le président
issoufou pour organiser des élections de
référence pour l'afrique a été saluée
unanimement effet autorités malgré
l'engagement au quotidien de notre
diplomatie en guinée ou en côte d'ivoire
par le public de la france n'y a pas
semblé aussi clair et aussi
incontestable monsieur ministre
pouvez-vous réaffirmé que la france est
et sera toujours du côté des peuples des
libertés publiques
monsieur le ministre que va faire la
france pour apaiser le climat de tension
et favoriser une sortie de crise qui
garantissent la liberté la sécurité et
de l'expression démocratique
merci chers collègues la parole et à
monsieur jean yves le drian venise de
l'europe des affaires étrangères
monsieur le député bruno fausses je vais
me concentrer sur la situation en côte
d'ivoire puisque j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de m'exprimer ici sur la guinée
l'élection qui avait lieu un peu
antérieurement et là sur la côte
d'ivoire étant donné que ces élections
se sont tenues le 31 octobre
il ya une actualité plus prégnant
d'autant plus que comme vous le savez le
conseil constitutionnel de côte d'ivoire
a rendu public que les résultats de
l'élection présidentielle
hier la voix de la france est en côte
d'ivoire elle est forte
y compris lorsque moi même je me suis
rendu en côte d'ivoire au moment où la
question du troisième mandat se posait
et nous avons à plusieurs reprises en
parfaite harmonie avec le l'union
européenne fait valoir nos inquiétudes
sur les le climat de tension qui a
prévalu durant la tenue de ce scrutin et
nous avons condamné les violences
intervenues avant pendant et depuis le
scrutin
hélas aujourd'hui nous appelons
l'ensemble des acteurs ivoiriens à la
responsabilité au rejet des discours de
haine et ne nous retrouvons tout à fait
dans les propos exprimés par le
secrétaire général des nations unies
hier concernant les arrestations les
restrictions à la liberté de mouvement
dans certains acteurs politiques
ivoiriens font actuellement l'objet le
président ouattara s'est exprimé hier
devant son pays en proposant un dialogue
avec l'ancien premier président monsieur
bédié
cela va dans le bon sens et nous
souhaitons par contre est clairement que
des actes contribuer rapidement à
l'apaisement des mesures concrètes et
rapides aurait deux prises pour tourner
la page de la violence et de la division
nous pensons aussi que le règlement des
différends entre les autorités et
l'opposition
on doit se faire sur une base inclusive
en associant l'ensemble des forces
politiques du pays dans le respect dans
le respect du cadre constitutionnel dans
le respect de l'état de droit
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur dominique potier merci
monsieur le président permettez moi en
cette veille de commémoration de
l'armistice tout d'abord de saluer le
fait que l'itinéraire vers le panthéon
de maurice genevoix soit passer par la
crête des éparges je le dis au nom de
tous les élus des terres de lorraine
ils ont été très honoré par cet
itinéraire là nous voulions dire ici je
voudrais vous dire chers amis que nous
avons je pense surtout nos bons été ému
par les paroles de schweigen vendredi
soir lorsqu'il y a dit je ne vois plus
d'états rouge je ne vois plus d'états
bleus je vois des états unis la formule
par sa limpidité nous a frappé mon
allemands interrogés comme peut-être
beaucoup d'autres pourquoi n'arrivons
nous pas dans notre pays monsieur le
premier ministre sur l'essentiel à nous
réunir à nous retrouver
vous le savez nous avons tous peut-être
une part de responsabilité mais en tout
cas elle n'est pas uniquement du fait
des oppositions je le crois profondément
se joue à dire c'est que sur ces choses
essentielles sur lesquelles nous
pourrions nous retrouver
il me semble qu'il ya la question des
questions d'éthique et sur ces questions
d'éthique
nous avons pris deux initiatives sur les
deux bords de l'assemblée il y a 6 mois
une question écrite sans réponse comme
tant d'autres poser la question d'une
saisine plus systémique du delà du
comité consultatif national d'éthique
sur les questions de gestion de la
pandémie
j'évoquais notamment la question de la
priorisation des patients la question
des soins palliatifs et de leur culture
en situation d'urgence
j'évoquais la question du traitement des
corps et des rituels de deuil
si chère à notre civilisation nous avons
évoqué cette saisine est au même moment
un mois plus tard il ya cinq mois
notre collègue xavier breton a proposé
une proposition de loi qu'elle est dans
le même sens et qui proposait une
saisine systématique aux au sénat ne
s'est pas prononcé mais nous l'avons
voté à l'unanimité le calendrier
sanitaire s'est accéléré pouvez vous
monsieur le premier ministre mais ce que
vous avez la faculté sans même attendre
le vote du scène
saisir organiser une saisine du comité
national d'éthique afin que nous ayons
un éclairage sur ce qui s'est passé en
mars jusqu'en juillet et que nous ayons
éclairer sur les questions de dignité
humaine pour les semaines qui viennent
merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur n'dri attaqué secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre des solidarités et de
la santé merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député dominique
potier au fond ce que seul et votre
question essentielle c'est la
concurrence des temporalités temporalité
entre le temps long de la réflexion
éthique et le temps cours de l'action
quand une vie est menacée et que l'on ne
peut pas se permettre d'attendre ce sont
des réflexions une tension auxquels nous
avons de tout temps été confrontés les
professionnels de santé au premier chef
et qui est effectivement d'autant plus
prévenante encore aujourd'hui et cette
concurrence entre ces temps doit être
surmontées alors vous le savez notre
pays dispose d'outils unique au monde
pour que les inventer techniques
technologiques ne soit pas hors de
contrôle et c'est tout le sens des lois
de bioéthique qui ont lieu donné lieu à
de nombreux débats ici notamment avec
votre collègue breton et puis nous avons
des instances qui peuvent formuler des
avis et qui permettent à des
scientifiques mais aussi à des
philosophes à des à des citoyens à des
praticiens de questionner ces tensions à
l'oeuvre et c'est le cas du comité
national consultatif national d'éthique
qui peut être saisie sans restriction en
période d'état d'urgence et c'est ce que
le gouvernement a fait depuis le mois de
mars dernier une première fois le 13
mars le conseil a pu rendre un avis sur
les enjeux éthiques
face à une pandémie le 1er avril navy
sur le renforcement des mesures de
protection dans les ehpad et les unités
de longue durée ou encore en mai dernier
les enjeux éthiques lors du
déconfinement responsabilité solidarité
et confiance de sujet sur lequel je vais
revenir plus précisément ce que vous les
avez cité je sais que vous y êtes
particulièrement attaché la question
effectivement des funérailles de
nombreuses familles ont été durement
affectés parce qu'elles n'ont pas pu
assister aux funérailles et je crois que
nous pouvons dire qu'aujourd'hui en
cette deuxième vague de confinement les
choses se sont améliorées notamment
suite aux recommandations formulées par
le comité national consultatif des
siliques à cet égard deuxième sujet la
question de la fin de vie
sur lesquels vous êtes engagé depuis de
nombreuse de nombreuses années qu'ils ne
sont pas des questions secondaires elles
sont cruciales pour chacun d'entre nous
pour nos concitoyens je crois pour la
société toute entière
nous tirons les laissons éthique de
cette crise et vous savez c'est la
raison pour laquelle je conclu monsieur
le président le 12 octobre dernier
olivier ferrand à l'occasion de la
journée mondiale de soins palliatifs a
lancé des travaux sur ce sujet là même
qui intègre ayons toutes les leçons de
cette crise
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
madame catherine favre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères en ce
moment même à l'assemblée générale de
l'om s 32 pays dont nos voisins
européens la pologne et la hongrie ont
décidé de présenter une déclaration
commune rétrograde et inquiétante qui
clame l'opposition de ses états au droit
à l'avortement
cette déclaration s'inscrit
malheureusement dans une offensive
actuelle contre le droit des femmes pour
lesquelles ne nous y trompons pas rien
n'est jamais acquis
ainsi en pologne en le tribunal
constitutionnel
encouragés par le parti ultra
conservateur au pouvoir a réduit à peau
de chagrin l'accès de ali vg des
centaines de milliers de polonais
protestent contre cette décision
depuis maintenant deux semaines ainsi
aux états unis où si l'élection de joe
biden est porteuse d'espoir la marque de
son prédécesseur mettra du temps à
s'effacer en 93 jeune juge ultra
conservateur à la cour suprême
américaine donald trump l'a fait
basculer et ce pour des décennies
du côté des anti ivg ce risque permanent
qui pèsent sur les droits reproductifs
des femmes est inquiétant car il est
important de comprendre ce que savait
très bien nos grands mères et nos
arrière grands mères seules le fait de
maîtriser ces grossesses permettent à
une femme de conduire sa vie avec la
même liberté que peut le faire un homme
lorsque ces droits sont attaqués c'est
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
qui est attaqué cette égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes elle est inscrite
dans notre constitution depuis 1946 dans
notre état un européen depuis 1957
elle fait partie de notre identité et il
est de notre devoir de la protéger de la
défendre quand elle est en danger
monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères nous sommes fiers de la
france qui mène une diplomatie
féministe pour soutenir l'émancipation
des femmes à travers le monde alors
qu'allez vous faire pour montrer au
peuple polonais que nous sommes à ses
côtés
qu'allez-vous faire face à ces multiples
régression merci la pole comme c'est
jean yves le drian ministre des affaires
de l'europe et des affaires étrangères
et madame la députée nous avons pris
connaissance de la décision le 22
octobre dernier du tribunal
constitutionnel de pologne qui a comme
vous l'avez indiqué jugé
inconstitutionnel l'avortement pratiqué
en cas de malformations graves ou de
maladie incurable du foetus
ce qui aboutit donc à restreindre les
motifs possibles pour une ivg
ces décisions de justice a suscité de
vives réactions en pologne avec des
dizaines de milliers de manifestants et
une grève générale des femmes près de
cinq cent mille personnes ont manifesté
à ce moment là et je dois dire ici que
nous comprenons pleinement ses réactions
nous les soutenons car ce qui est en jeu
c'est le respect des droits fondamentaux
nous comprenons le soutenons en tant que
français bien sûr car ce combat pour
l'avortement est un combat qui renvoie à
l'histoire politique de notre pays
lorsque des femmes se sont mobilisés à
juste titre pour revendiquer le droit à
disposer de leur propre comme et ce
combat nous comprenons aussi en tant
qu'européen car je voulais le rappeler
l'union européenne c'est une communauté
de valeurs dont le fondement est le
respect des droits fondamentaux de la
liberté portait atteinte à ces derniers
c'est affaiblir la construction
européenne elle même et les droits et la
santé sexuelle et reproductive sont une
condition essentielle pour le
développement d'une société égalitaire
et justes et l'accès à un avortement
légal et médicalisée fait partie
intégralement de ses droits fondamentaux
est ce que nous souhaitons c'est que
lorsque nous allons organiser en juin
prochain avec le mexique à paris le
forum génération égalité qui rappellera
les 25 ans de la première initiative
prise à pékin cette question soit au
centre de nos discussions de nos
programmations et de nos engagements
merci monsieur le ministre avant de lui
donner la parole je suis heureux
souhaité la bienvenue aux dames sandra
boel devenu député de la 14e
circonscription de paris du 28 mai en
remplacement de notre regretté collègue
claude goasguen vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
monsieur le ministre
l'embargo des nations unies sur les
armes conventionnelles de à destination
de l'iran a expiré le 18 octobre dernier
le régime des mollahs s'en est
publiquement félicité la france n'a pas
tenu l'initiative des etats-unis pour
prolonger cet embargo de peur que
celle-ci n'entraîne la fin du jcp hoa et
pourtant il ne fait aucun doute que les
activités militaires de l'iran et des
milices qui lui sont inféodées ont un
impact déstabilisateur sur tout le
moyen-orient et particulièrement sur le
liban qui traverse une crise grave
notre pays bien placé pour savoir que la
fourniture d'armes aux milices
jihadistes et au hezbollah par l'iran
serait un élément supplémentaire de
déstabilisation qui ne ferait
qu'accroître les tensions au pays du
cèdre et dans toute la région ainsi
qu'en europe
c'est pourquoi la france doit prendre
ses responsabilités
alors monsieur le ministre je vous le
demande notre pays at il l'intention de
remettre la question de l'embargo des
armes de et vers l'iran à l'agenda du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
que comptez vous faire pour prévenir la
course aux armements que la levée de cet
embargo ne manquera pas de provoquer mon
deuxième point concerne le hesbollah le
bras armé de l'iran
nous faisons face est une organisation
terroriste qui a pris le liban en otage
avec les conséquences que l'on sait et
fomentent ainsi des attentats sur le sol
européen
les exemples et les informations ne
manquent pas c'est ce qui amenait déjà 8
de nos pays voisins dont l'allemagne et
le royaume uni à désigner le hezbollah
dans sa globalité
parce qu'il est vraiment une
organisation terroriste la france joue
un rôle moteur dans les diplomaties
européennes ne doivent la france qui
joue un rôle moteur dans la diplomatie
européenne ne doit plus attendre la
branche politique et la branche
militaire du hezbollah sont
indissociables puisque dirigé par un
seul et même chef
nous devons plus être dans l'ambiguïté
avec cette seule organisation terroriste
n'est-il pas temps monsieur le ministre
que la france prenne les mesures qui
s'imposent pour mettre le hesbollah hors
jeu pour envoyer un message de fermeté à
l'iran est constitué de nos alliés
européens américains et arabes
un front uni pour combattre enfin le
terrorisme et l'islamisme avec la
lucidité et les moyens appropriés
merci
jean yves le drian nice to l'europe et
des affaires étrangères madame madame la
députée sur la question iranienne et sur
la question du hezbollah je me suis déjà
expliqué à de nombreuses reprises dans
cette assemblée je voudrais simplement
vous rappeler que l'enjeu essentiel
concernant cette situation c'est le
respect du jcp haut à des accords de
vienne parce que l'enjeu essentiel c'est
d'éviter que l'iran accède à l'armé
nucléaire et que la meilleure manière
d'éviter l'accès de l'iran l'âme
nucléaire c'est le respect des accords
de vienne il se trouve qu'après le
retrait américain de jcp aux as
il y a eu une terrible iranienne que
nous condamnons et que progressivement
les iraniens en détricoter chapitre
après chapitre leurs engagements au
titre du jcp aussi bien qu'aujourd'hui
ça ne tient plus qu'à un fil et donc je
souhaite que dans avec la nouvelle
administration américaine nous puissions
renouer le dialogue pour juguler les
trois tentatives grave car l'iran
aujourd'hui d'une part la tentation de
revenir sur l'accord nucléaire et de se
doter lui-même de l'arme nucléaire et à
ce moment là deux stades déstabiliser
considérablement l'ensemble de la région
c'est le premier risque le deuxième
c'est cette espèce de frénésie missiles
hier qui est s'est emparé de ce pays et
qui fait que avec le dispositif qui l'on
ait la capacité de production d'armes
ils puissent renforcer des perturbations
et des déstabilisations dans plusieurs
pays
le yémen voir le liban et la troisième
le troisième ris et les risques de
déstabilisation globale de la zone par
des interventions dans le golfe
par exemple il y a donc l'ensemble de
ces questions à régler avec l'iran et il
faut essayer de s'engager dans un
nouveau processus politique qui est
indispensable à dans la période que nous
traversons par rapport au hezbollah
le président a appelé moi-même nous
avons toujours dit que nous condamnons
le
certes les actions du hezbollah nous
avons considéré le hezbollah militaire
était une organisation terroriste mais
lui reste dans la politique il est élu
par les libanais c'est comme ça il ya
des députés du hezbollah qui sont
libanais votée par les libanais et donc
nous sommes bien obligés de constater
qu'ils sont là qu'ils existent et qu'il
faut essayer de faire avec
dans les meilleures conditions ça nous
empêche pas comme l'a fait le président
la république lorsque le dernier
gouvernement libanais potentiel n'a pas
pu aboutir de condamner fermement le
fait que ce serait laisser le hezbollah
qui avait trahi ses engagements
et quand monsieur le drian la parole
nous promettent de fonctionne en temps
breton ce qui explique des distributions
la parole est à monsieur charles de
courson ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre votre gouvernement a déposé le
samedi 7 novembre à 12h52 un amendement
sur la deuxième partie du projet loi de
finances pour 2021 lui donnant la
possibilité de renégocier à la baisse
les tarifs des 800 plus gros contrats de
production d'électricité photovoltaïque
conclu entre 2006 et 2010 cela pose
plusieurs problèmes
un problème de méthode tout d'abord qui
traduit un manque de respect à l'égard
du parlement
l'amendement était introduit comme
d'habitude la dernière minute sans
examen commission et sans étude d'impact
pour exposé des motifs peu claires et la
dame blanche que vous faites circuler
uniquement parmi les seuls députés de la
majorité n'apporte que peu
d'éclaircissements sur les conséquences
de cet amendement sur le fond ensuite en
revenant sur un engagement de l'état
vous faites porter le discrédit sur la
parole de l'état la rétroactivité de la
mesure pose en outre un vrai problème
constitutionnel au regard du respect du
droit de propriété
quant aux conséquences économiques sur
la filière du photovoltaïque vous
feignez de les oublier
notamment en outre mer et dans les zones
non interconnectées
la faille de beaucoup de sociétés de
projet est pourtant un risque réel
puisque 90% des détenteurs actuels de
ces contrats ne sont pas leurs
détenteurs initiaux d'ailleurs dans
votre amendement vous ouvrez une
possibilité de dérogation au risque de
tomber dans l'arbitraire
quant aux économies attendues votre
exposé des motifs et muet la cour des
comptes dans ce rapport de mars 2018
indiqué que les garanties accordées au
photovoltaïque est allé
lien au shore représenterait chacun 2
milliards d'euros par an dont 750
millions pour les 800 plus gros contrats
visés par votre amendement et quel est
le montant
monsieur le premier ministre des
économies espérées
ainsi monsieur le premier ministre alors
où vous nous annoncez un pas de géant en
faveur de l'écologie
quelle est la cohérence de votre
politique énergétique merci les gars
barbara pompili ministre de la
transition écologique
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député charles de courson
je vous le confirme tout d'abord
l'objectif du gouvernement est bien de
soutenir massivement le développement
des énergies renouvelables comme en
témoignent les 110 milliards d'euros
d'engagements à couvrir sur 20 ans ou
encore l'accroissement à venir de 25% du
soutien financier aux énergies
renouvelables pour 2020 et 2021
nous avons notamment prévu des prochains
appels d'offres pour plus de 10
gigawatts d'installations
photovoltaïques au cours des cinq
prochaines années
concernant la mesure dont vous parlez de
révision de contrats photovoltaïques
signées entre 2006 et 2010 il s'agit de
revenir sur une petite minorité de
contrat on parle de 800 contrats sur les
235 milles qui existent et qui
concernent des décès installations qui
sont déjà amortis qui ont bénéficié d'un
rendement du capital parfois supérieures
à 20% aux frais du contribuable ces
contrats bénéficient aujourd'hui d'un
tarif de rachat garanti qui peut
atteindre 600 euros par mégawattheure
acquis après un phénomène de bulle
si nous ne faisons rien et voilà l'étude
d'impact monsieur de courson le
contribuable devra débourser d'ici dix
ans plus de 20 milliards d'euros pour
rémunérer l'ensemble de ses contrats
alors que moins de subventions
permettrait de près de maintenir la même
production d'énergie renouvelable en
rémunérant de manière normale des
producteurs cette rente photovoltaïque
c'est autant de ressources en moins pour
développer de nouvelles installations
d'énergies renouvelables j'insiste sur
le fait que ce sera une révision cible
et qu'elle sera juste
nous avons travaillé avec la filière
nous avons défini avec une clause de
sauvegarde qui permettra au cas par cas
de regarder pour éviter que une révision
de contrat puisse mettre en péril
l'exploitation est donc effectivement
nous regarderons ça finement
examineront les cas particulier de la
corse et de l'outre-mer qui présente des
spécificités que nous connaissons en
outre nous ne révélerons pas les
contrats pour des installations dont la
puissance est inférieure à 200 kilowatts
crête ce qui protège des facto les
particuliers et la quasi-totalité des
agriculteurs c'est une mesure introduite
à la suite de nombreux échanges menés
avec la filière vous l'avez compris
monsieur députés le but est de revenir
sur une rente de situation qui est
injustifiée inutile sans déstabiliser
l'équilibré financier de la filière que
nous continuerons bien entendu à
soutenir le début madame la ministre
vous avez donc lui plus de trois ans
pour découvrir cette situation qui n'est
pas d'ailleurs spécifique à cette
filière par parenthèse et quelque sorte
vous avez l'amour vache c'est à dire que
pour favoriser le développement de ces
énergies vous commencez par les
sanctionner merci monsieur le député la
parole à madame sylvie charrière merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
de la ville ce parlement et votre
majorité viennent d'adopter un budget
historique pour la politique de la ville
en hausse de 10% à l'heure où les enjeux
dans nos quartiers sont immenses ce
gouvernement et cette majorité répondent
avec des moyens et des actions inédites
nous n'avons pas attendu la crise
sanitaire pour faire des quartiers
politique de la ville une priorité en
effet dès 2018 jean michel blanquer
julien normandie que je remercie de
nouveaux ont annoncé la création de 80
cité éducative suite à une préconisation
du rapport de jean louis borloo
les sites et éducatives sont avant tout
une grande alliance des acteurs
éducatifs travaillant dans les quartiers
prioritaires de la politique de la ville
pour faire de la réussite de nos enfants
un enjeu fort elle vise à intensifier
les prises en charge éducative des
enfants de leur naissance jusqu'à
l'insertion professionnelle avant
pendant autour et après l'école tous les
acteurs du territoire doivent se
mobiliser ensemble services de l'état
collectivités associations habitants
tous unis autour d'un même objectif d'un
même projet vous l'avez compris c'est
cité éducative ne constitue pas un
énième dispositif mais c'est avant tout
un état d'esprit une méthode de travail
qui part des besoins et des aspirations
d'un territoire
à l'épreuve du premier confinement les
sites et éducatives ont fait la preuve
de leur efficacité de leur pertinence
un avis du comité national d'orientation
et d'évaluation des sites et éducatives
que j'ai l'honneur de présider souligne
à quel point ces nouveaux écosystèmes
territoriaux ont permis des réponses
rapides et adaptées aux besoins des
enfants et des jeunes durant la crise
fort de cette réussite
vous avez annoncé madame la ministre en
compagnie de madame de secrétaire d'état
à l'éducation prioritaire
la création de 40 nouvelle cité
éducative
je ne peux que m'en réjouir et le budget
que nous venons d'adopter concrétise cet
objectif madame la ministre
pouvez-vous détailler le déploiement à
venir des nouvelles cités éducatives
ainsi que l'ensemble des actions que
vous menez à destination de nos
quartiers politique de la ville dans le
cadre de ce projet je vous remercie
merci on a débuté la parole et à madame
nadia ministre délégué chargé de la
ville merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée sylvie charrière merci pour
votre question et surtout merci pour
avoir joué ce rôle dans la création des
sites éducatifs valeur à ce jour ce sont
500 25000 jeunes qui sont accompagnés
par les sites éducative soit un jeune
sur carte
quatre de nos quartiers prioritaires
vous avez raison les sites éducatifs
c'est bien plus qu'un dispositif
c'est une méthode de travail qui place
l'enfant au centre de l'action
collective et ceci permet d'organiser la
continuité éducative et d'ouvrir le
champ des possibles il s'agit du plus
grand d'investissement du ministère de
la ville après la création de l'anru le
budget que vous avez votés ce week end
conforte une augmentation de 10% pour la
politique de la ville et qui va
permettre le déploiement de 40 sites et
nouvelle vous l'avait dit et nous les
avons annoncé récemment avec nathalie et
limaces secrétaire d'état à l'éducation
prioritaire
ce cette annonce porte le nombre à 120
cité éducative en france l'ambition est
de monter en gamme sur l'offre
culturelle et sportive et où l'esprit
critique et le sens du respect de
l'autre permet de construire les jeunes
citoyens
2 demain dans le même budget l'emploi
est une priorité et c'est pourquoi nous
consacrons 10 millions d'euros pour
augmenter le nombre de postes adulte
relais et le porter à 6500 nous portons
également à 32 millions d'euros la
participation du ministère de la ville
dans les établissements publics
d'insertion et nous créons aussi les
nouvelles cités de l'emploi qui à
l'instar des sites et éducatives
mobiliseront l'ensemble des acteurs et
des opérateurs de l'état pour sortir
d'une logique de dispositif est entré
dans une logique de parcours pour aller
vers chaque habitant de nos quartiers
c'est avec de telles actions concrètes
que nous poursuivrons notre objectif de
cohésion nationale le président de la
république l'a réaffirmé aux mureaux
l'etat sera aux côtés de celles et ceux
qui font vivre la république au
quotidien nous leur devons temps car ils
portent en eux la promesse républicaine
merci flamini avant d'appeler la
dernière question je vous rappelle qu'à
l'issue des questions au gouvernement
la séance ne sera pas suspendue car je
prononcerai éloge funèbre de françois
andré
je salue les membres de sa famille
quelques uns d'entre eux et quelques-uns
de ses amis qui ont rejoint les tribunes
du public
la parole est à madame clémentine autain
une nouvelle fois les hypermarchés sont
ouverts pendant le confinement alors que
de nombreux commerces de proximité ont
fermé boutique
à quelle logique sanitaire répond
l'ouverture de grands espaces bondé et
climatisées plutôt que de petits
magasins de proximité avec moins de
monde et plus facile à errer vous n'avez
même pas su organiser à temps
l'information et le versement des
maigres aides consenties à ses petites
entreprises si bien que certaines auront
mis la clé sous la porte avant d'en
avoir touché un centime
devant la colère qui gronde vous avez
procédé à des ajustements jusqu'à
l'absurde
fini les livres ou les chaussettes dans
les hypermarchés vous prétendez ainsi
protéger les libraires les boutiques de
vêtements ou les fleuristes d'une
concurrence déloyale comme si amazon et
consorts qui s'épanouissent sur le web
en surexploitant des employés précaires
sans payer leurs impôts ne constituait
pas la menace la plus violente
comme si l'enjeu n'était qu'une affaire
de concurrence mesurez-vous ce qui se
joue c'est la vie de millions de
personnes menacées de perdre leur emploi
mais aussi pour certains leur maison
leur voiture sur lesquels leur
entreprise est gagé c'est aussi la
désertification des villes de demain qui
va fatalement s'aggraver c'est enfin une
société d'hyperconsommation déshumanisé
que vous accélérez en réalité votre
décision signe un choix de société celui
de la croissance et de la compétitivité
depuis longtemps l'hypermarché a été
soutenue et encouragée par les
politiques publiques les perdants ce
sont les petits commerces et l'artisanat
qui participe pourtant de la vitalité de
tant de villes qui tisse du lien de
proximité et qui nous libère du tout
voiture les perdants ce sont aussi les
consommateurs devenus souvent au nom des
prix mais pas seulement dépendant des
grandes surfaces laisser mourir les
petits commerçants et les artisans est
indécent quand on voit les milliards
d'argent public que vous continuez
d'attribuer aux grands groupes et les
profits que continuent d'engranger la
grande distribution
monsieur le ministre quand allez vous
arrêter ce carnage économique social
environnemental
merci madame atteint par l'auto madame
agnès ce pénurie lâche et ministre
délégué chargé de l'industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
autun bien au contraire tous les jours
depuis le mois de mars
nous sommes aux côtés des petits
commerçants et des petits artisans pour
les soutenir
bien au contraire c'est la france qui a
déployé le plan le plus important de
soutien aux petits commerçants et aux
petits artisans
diane au contraire la stratégie que nous
avons lancé dès octobre 2018 pour les
petits commerçants et des artisans se
déploie avec l'appui en supplément du
plan d'urgence 15 milliards d'euros pour
le seul mois de novembre
on appuie notamment de ces petits
commerçants et des artisans
ces dix mille euros que nous allons
donner pour accompagner ces entreprises
en difficulté qui ont dû fermer à cause
de conditions sanitaires
ce sont les commerces de
l'agroalimentaire qui continuent à être
ouvert et que vous avez l'air d'ignorer
qu'ils aussi assurent ce service public
pour alimenter les français alors
mesdames autun regardons les choses en
face
notre boussole c'est l'emploi
aujourd'hui nous avons réussi à empêcher
la disparition de ces petits commerçants
et de ses artisans parce que nous avons
mis le paquet
et lorsque l'on regarde le taux de
faillite on peut observer qu'il est
inférieure inférieure à celui l'année
dernière le combat n'est pas terminé
nous sommes d'accord et nous allons le
continuer avec vous je l'espère pour
faire en sorte que ces petits
commerçants et ses artisans passe la
crise avec les exonérations de taxes
sociales de cotisations sociales avec
les aides massives que nous leur
apportons avec le soutien que nous
faisons pour la numérisation de ces
commerçants et de ses artisans et avec
l'appui aux salariés de ces petits
commerçants de ces artisans qui sont
aussi accompagnées temps c'est leur
importance sur les territoires et dans
les petits bourgs et ce n'est pas à
jacqueline gourault la ministre à la
cohésion des territoires qui dira le
contraire
merci madame l'avenir
[Applaudissements]